festhalten in den Deutschen Bundestag
zur wahrscheinlich letzten Sitzungswoche
des Parlaments Erhard schärfer ist für
uns vor Ort und er hat gestern
mitgebracht
ja danke Tina das heißt es ist nicht nur
die letzte Sitzungswoche in diesem Jahr
es ist sogar der Letzte Sitzungstag und
wie ist der Bundestag so will hat er
noch mal oder das Programm einfach nicht
aufgemischt hat zwei Tagesordnungspunkte
nach vorne geschoben die ursprünglich
gar nicht da gewesen sind nämlich es
geht um den Schützen sogenannter
Whistleblower und um die Stärkung der
Bundespolizei uns hat das nicht
angefochten wir sind bei dem Thema
geblieben dass wir sowieso vorhatten um
diese Zeit dann geht es nämlich um das
Engagement und haben das Ehrenamt also
freiwilliges Engagement da liegt dann
als dritter Tagesordnungspunkt heute der
sogenannte dritte engagementberichte der
Bundesregierung es ist die vorige
Bundesregierung übrigens noch gewesen
vor und wird hier diskutiert und wir
fanden da ist so viel Thema drin und so
viel Stoff und so viel interessante
Punkte dass wir das durchaus auch an
dieser Stelle immer diskutieren sollten
und wir können das machen weil der die
große Frage ist wie wird sich das in
Zukunft entwickeln wir hören von vielen
Egoismen in der Gesellschaft
gleichzeitig wächst der Bedarf an auch
freiwilligen im Engagement und die Frage
ist halt wie lässt sich da die Waage
finden und da sollen wir jetzt mal
besprechen vorab schon mal mit Helge
lind der ist Sprecher der ag-demokratie
in der SPD-Bundestagsfraktion und bei
uns ist außerdem Volker Ulrich der ihnen
und rechtspolitische Sprecher der CSU
Landesgruppe ihnen beiden guten Morgen
schön dass Sie da sind Herr Lindt als
Bundestagsabgeordneter habe ich gesehen
sie sind in 14 Vereinen bzw
Organisationen Mitglied haben außerdem
noch zwei kommunalpolitische Mandate
welches ehrenamtliche welche
ehrenamtliche Tätigkeit haben Sie
zuletzt noch ausgeübt
also ganz aktuell ist es wahrscheinlich
der 15 Verein weil ich Vorsitzender des
Pina Baus Fördervereins in meinem heiß
geliebten Wuppertal geworden
es sind wahrscheinlich noch viel mehr
Vereine also ich versuche trotz allem
trotz aller berufspolitischen Arbeit
diese Erdung durchs Ehrenamt noch weiter
zu treiben aber ohne allzu viele Posten
zu sammeln das ist nämlich auch eine
Gefahr der man als Politiker täglich
ausgesetzt ist wie sieht es bei Ihnen
aus der Ulrich Ehrenamt gehört zu ihrem
Arbeitskreis den sie leiten
ja ganz persönlich habe ich mich mit der
Wahl in den Deutschen Bundestag von der
Spitze oder vom Vorstand mehrerer
Vereine zurückgezogen um mich auf Mann
mein Mandat konzentrieren zu können
gleichwohl bin ich Mitglied in
zahlreichen Fördervereinen bei einer
freiwilligen Feuerwehr bei colping ich
bin natürlich kein aktiver Feuerwehr das
muss ich auch dazu sagen aber ich
fördere eine freiwillige Feuerwehr in
Augsburg und ich finde der Kontakt mit
den Menschen auf zahlreiche
Mitgliederversammlungen die diese
Vereine und Organisation am Laufen
halten sind nicht nur wichtig für die
politische Arbeit hier sondern zeigen
diese ganze Fülle großartigen
Engagements in eine Gesellschaft und
zeigt uns auch wie lebendig Engagement
Ehrenamt doch sein kann und wie wichtig
ist es haben wir eben auch gehört und es
gibt immer viel Lob und Anerkennung bei
offiziellen Gelegenheiten sie beide
haben sie ja eben auch gemacht völlig zu
Recht im übrigen aber wird es trotzdem
hinreichend gewürdigt jenseits der
warmen Worte nein eindeutiges nein aus
meiner Sicht man muss ja so sehen wenn
man es mal beschreiben will dass
Ehrenamt ist ja sowas wie so einer
Keimzelle für Respekt und Aufmerksamkeit
also wir haben das gesehen für Themen
Klimaschutz flüchtlingskrise teilweise
armuts Bekämpfung also bei vielen
relevanten Themen war wenn man genau
hinguckt dass Ehrenamt viel schneller
und pragmatischer und unlogmatischer und
ideologischer als die politische Debatte
oft erleben wir aber dann das nach dem
Bekundungen sehr großartig was ihr macht
und auch Ehrung in der langen Strecke
die Unterstützung fehlt und das ist auch
die Rückmeldung die ich oft bekomme von
Ehrenamtlichen dass sie sich im Stich
gelassen fühlen deshalb ist da noch
dringender handlungsunterstützungsbedarf
welche welche Unterstützung würden Sie
für zwingend halten jetzt mal so langsam
meine ganz persönliche Beobachtung und
Einschätzung ist dass viele Menschen die
sich ehrenamtlich engagieren zunächst
gar nicht danach fragen bekommen sie von
Seiten des Staates dafür eine Belohnung
sondern sie machen es für sich selbst
aber vor allen Dingen auch für andere
Menschen
Senioren die in den Schulen Vorlesen
Menschen die für fahrfeste Kuchen backen
Sie machen es einfach um einen Beitrag
für die Gesellschaft zu leisten dass
darüber hinaus die Frage steht wie kann
der Staat besser die Menschen
unterstützen oder ihnen auch Anerkennung
sollen die sich jahrelang ehrenamtlich
engagieren das meine ich ist noch davon
zu trennen okay ich glaube wir brauchen
noch eine stärkere Anerkennungskultur im
Ehrenamt vor allen Dingen aber auch die
Frage wie können wir dafür Sorge tragen
dass in vielen
bedeutende kritischen Bereichen des
Ehrenamtes Katastrophenschutz Feuerwehr
Rettungsdienst auch die Vereinbarkeit
übrigens von Ehrenamt und Beruf stärker
und einen Hut gebracht werden kann aber
bleiben wir da mal bei was wenn dann
ihre konkreten Vorschläge also wir
setzen voraus die Leute machen das
tatsächlich freiwillig und warten nicht
auf
großartigen Lohn gleichwohl brauchen Sie
Unterstützung beispielsweise wenn sie
irgendwo hinfahren müssen dass der
vielleicht ein Ticket kriegen für einen
öffentlichen Personennahverkehr oder
ähnliche Dinge wie kann das konkret
aussehen ich kann mir vorstellen dass
wir zum einen im Steuerrecht etwas tun
eine Art der Ehrenamtspauschale im
Steuerrecht ich kann mir vorstellen dass
wir gerade auch für junge Menschen die
sich engagieren auch
gewisse benefits ausreichen die
entscheidende Frage ist auch die wie ein
Stück weit auch die Freistellung vom
Beruf passieren kann
klar Ehrenamt ist nicht der Beruf aber
ich finde schon dass gerade wenn es um
Feuerwehr geht da gibt es gesetzliche
Ansprüche aber es müsste vielleicht dem
ein oder anderen Fall auch noch
einfacher gehen wenn ich jetzt haben sie
gerade beide festgestellt irgendwie dass
es da enorme Defizite gibt und jetzt
frage ich sie beide in der
hintereinander irgendwie warum ist da
bislang noch nichts passiert wenn der
der Tatbestand ist doch es ist bekannt
die die Leistung der Menschen wird
anerkannt deswegen habe ich wir haben am
Anfang auch sehr vehement gesagt nein es
wird es wird zu wenig getan warum
passiert dann nichts weil Demokratie in
unserem Land oft langsam ist was auch
nicht schlecht ist weil wir lange braten
und weil glaube ich die Wachsamkeit und
die Aufmerksamkeit für Ehrenamt erst in
letzter Zeit im politischen Raum so
gewachsen ist und man sieht ja das was
passiert wir haben eine Deutsche
Stiftung für Engagement und Ehrenamt
dies lange nicht gab in der letzten
Legislatur übrigens noch in der großen
Koalition auf den Weg gebracht es wird
künftig hoffentlich an Demokratie
fördergesetz geben also die Botschaft
ist leider spät angekommen und nicht nur
in den Kommunen sondern hier im
politischen Raum und ich glaube um das
neue ergänzen können wir können auch
wenn wir das
Gemeinnützigkeitsrecht uns angucken
dass wir auf der Höhe der Zeit sind weil
eben Ehrenamt nicht mehr nur im Verein
passiert aber immer noch auch in der
Form sondern in loseren Verbänden in
jungen Initiativen etc die war auch so
ein schutzkorridor brauchen um dann frei
agieren zu können ich bin der
Vorbereitung schönes Beispiel gefunden
ein Dänemark die zweitgrößte dänische
Bank lässt ihre Mitarbeiter in der
Arbeitszeit ehrenamtliche Tätigkeiten
machen das heißt sie werden in der Zeit
voll bezahlt ist das vorstellbar hierher
Ulrich ganz ehrlich ich kenne ja einige
Unternehmen die das so handhaben gerade
die familiengeführten übrigens die sogar
stolz darauf sind dass ihr
Abteilungsleiter oder
die Buchhalterin sich im Rettungsdienst
und in der Feuerwehr engagiert der Punkt
ist leiten wir daraus einen
Rechtsanspruch ab oder nicht ich meine
wenn wir von Engagement sprechen geht
das auch um gewisses Bewusstsein in der
Gesellschaft und ich würde mich freuen
wenn zahlreiche Arbeitgeber mehr diese
Haltung haben ja ich freue mich wenn
auch mal in der Mittagspause sogar
während der Arbeitszeit der eine oder
andere Mitarbeiter sich um sein Ehrenamt
kümmert aber die Menschen die freiwillig
tätig sind und sich freiwillig und
ehrenamtlich engagieren übernehmen ja
häufig Aufgaben von denen man auch sagen
könnte da wäre unter Umständen
vielleicht auch der Staat zuständig es
ist doppelgesichtig also wir haben zum
Teil diese Kompensation armutsbereich
Tafeln etc eigentlich ein Skandal dass
es Tafeln gibt und geben muss wir sehen
aber momentan die Zahlen werden immer
höher es funktioniert nicht ohne das hat
auch mit Scheitern von Sozialsystem zu
tun trotzdem und deshalb ist es beides
ist es auch erfüllend für die Menschen
das heißt viele wollen auch ehrenamtlich
arbeiten also es ist beides tatsächlich
manchmal lückenbüßen ganz oft aber die
Lust und die Freude von Menschen sich zu
engagieren und zwar nicht nach Vorgaben
der Politik sondern Eigeninitiative und
den eigenen Verantwortung machen sich
machen sich Kommunen Länder oder auch
der bunten schlanken Fuß in der Hoffnung
dass die Menschen ähm genau das erfüllen
was gerade beschrieben hat
nein das glaube ich nicht Herr Schäfer
aber ich will schon betonen dass gerade
in dem Bereich Rettungsdienst Feuerwehr
und Katastrophenschutz es sich natürlich
um genuin staatliche Aufgaben handelt
die der Staat aber nur deswegen
bewerkstelligen kann weil es im Bereich
des Katastrophenschutzes zahlreiche
ehrenamtliche Kräfte gibt hier
unterstützen ehrenamtliche übrigens mit
ihrer Zeit aber auch teilweise in den
einsetzen mit Gefahr für ihr Leben eine
staatliche Aufgabe für die Gemeinschaft
und da zeigt sich dass bei dem Ehrenamt
eben doch auch das Böcken für die dictum
gilt nämlich dass der Staat von
Voraussetzungen lebt die er selbst nicht
schaffen kann also der Staat lebt von
den ehrenamtlichen im staatlichen
Bereich selbst aber auch der
Zusammenhalt in eine Gesellschaft
nämlich für den anderen Menschen
einzustehen Solidarität zu zeigen keine
kalte egoistische Gesellschaft zu haben
ist wichtig für ein demokratisches
Gemeinwesen und das wird durch das
Ehrenamts auch bewerkstelligt
Böckenförde dictum inhaltlich erklärt
vielleicht müssen Sie noch mal ein
Stichwort geben für all die die damit
nichts mit dem Begriff nichts anfangen
können ja Böcken ein
Verfassungsrichter und Rechtsprofessor
in
Freiburg und er hat in einer bekannten
Schrift den Satz formuliert der Staat
lebt von Voraussetzungen die er selbst
nicht schaffen kann dieser Satz ist oft
zitiert aber er ist auch vielschichtig
interpretierbar nicht nur im Hinblick
auf geistige moralische Voraussetzung
soll sich auch im Hinblick auf das was
Menschen tun um eine Gesellschaft Halt
zu geben und Solidarität und
mitmenschlichkeiten damit auch würde
ihre Geltung zu verschaffen gucken
aufeinander Punkte in eine große Rolle
spielt bei diesem Bereich wir es gibt ja
die Ehrenamtler im kleinen also in
Kirchengemeinden bei Sportvereinen etc
alles was dazu gehört aber zunehmend
wieder Bedarf an Freiwilligen auch
größer ähm im großen Krankenhäusern
Pflege die Feuerwehr sie haben sie
angesprochen wiederholt und das vor
allem auch von der änderten
Grundvoraussetzungen also wir haben mehr
Naturkatastrophen beispielsweise die
Pandemie war da Kriegsflüchtlinge wo die
Menschen sehr intensiv geholfen haben in
den vergangenen Jahren da kommen die
Freiwilligendienste ins Spiel also rund
100.000 sind das im Jahr die die solche
Dienste leisten und da kommt das
verpflichtende Jahr in die Debatte was
wir im vergangenen Monaten auch
wiederholt gehört haben Dienstpflicht
deutschlanddienst gesellschaftsjahr
viele Namen gibt dafür was ist ihre
Position dazu
intuitiv hatte ich immer meine Grund
Sympathie dafür aber Politik ist ja mehr
als die eigene Intuition und als der
eigene innere Schweinehund deshalb habe
ich mir auch immer genau angeguckt auch
in meiner Arbeitsgruppe auch in
Gesprächen Mitarbeitenden auch jungen
Leuten gerade was haltet ihr davon und
die Antwort war oft sehr sehr deutlich
und sehr differenziert wir brauchen mehr
Unterstützung wir wollen uns engagieren
das
bundesfreiwilliger der
Bundesfreiwilligendienst das freiwillige
Sozialarbeit muss besser unterstützen
aber bitte
erfordert uns kein Pflichtjahr das wird
als Bevormundung begriffen und das nehme
ich sehr ernst ich will nicht an jungen
Leuten vor bei Ihnen ein Dienstjahr auf
oktoyieren dass wer nicht mein
Verständnis sondern es muss ein
gemeinsames Modell gehen weil es ja
gerade auch junge Menschen betrifft wie
wir Freiwilligendienst stärken das wäre
meine Einsatz
[Musik]
sie sind christlich in der
christlich-sozialen Union ihre
Schwesterpartei die CDU hat beim letzten
Parteitag mehrheitlich dafür gestimmt
dass ein solches Jahr eingeführt wird
wie sieht es bei Ihnen aus wie sehen Sie
das es gab auch Kritik innerhalb der CDU
dazu also es gibt da unterschiedliche
Positionen auch aber wie gesagt
mehrheitlich dann abgestimmt für ein
solches ähm die Debatte auch sehr
aufmerksam bei diesem Sender übrigens wo
sonst
verfolgt ich finde es gibt
gefühlsmäßig Argumente die für eine
Dienstpflicht sprechen nämlich es hat
niemanden geschadet sich für das Land
einzusetzen ist doch gut wenn man sich
engagiert aber wenn man die Oberfläche
dieser Argumente wegnimmt dann muss es
aus meiner Sicht bei einem Nein für eine
allgemeine Dienstpflicht bleiben und
zwar aus dem einfachen Grund dass sich
Engagement für die Gesellschaft für den
Mitmenschen letztlich nicht durch Zwang
erzwingen kann sondern das muss aus
einer inneren Haltung kommen und darüber
hinaus und das darf ich dann auch als
Rechtspolitiker sagen sowohl Europarecht
Menschenrechtskonvention als auch unser
Grundgesetz würden das im Augenblick
verbieten zudem wären die Kosten nämlich
einen Verwaltungsapparat aufzubauen um
eine Dienstpflicht umzusetzen und auch
rechtlich durchzusetzen wären so hoch
das letztlich ein vernünftiger Staat
davon Abstand nehmen würde letztlich
meine ich muss es mehr Formen geben dass
wir freiwilliges Engagement auch an
freiwilliges Jahr stärker fördern auch
mit Maßnahmen die wir bislang nicht
vorgenommen haben aber ich meine nicht
dass es noch eine Zeit gibt für eine
allgemeine Dienstpflicht wir müssen
abschließen und ganz kurz auch noch mal
auf ihre handlungs- und Tätigkeitsfelder
gucken nämlich auf die Politik wenn wir
auf die kommunale Ebene gucken sich da
sehr viele Ehrenamtliche tätig und aber
zunehmend Anfeindungen ausgesetzt das
heißt das Interesse lässt
nachvollziehbar teilweise nach als nicht
nur Anfeindungen sind teilweise auch
Attentate sie kennen das auch bedro
aller verschiedenster Art was kann man
tun oder was denken Sie was muss hier
auf dieser Ebene getan werden damit in
diesem Bereich die Menschen wieder mehr
bereit sind da Verantwortung zu
übernehmen die sie ja im Unternehmen
wollen übernehmen wollen meine
Enzyklopädie von Morddrohung ist diese
Woche noch mal gewachsen es gibt ja
bestimmte Themen die das leider triggern
und daraus kann ich auch ableiten was
passieren muss also es muss zum einen
sichergestellt wenn das Leute die sich
in Initiativen Verein engagieren auch
kommunalpolitisch zum Beispiel Ihre
Adresse schützen können da gibt es ja
Möglichkeiten die haben wir immer
Hassrede gesetzt in der letzten
Legislatur schon erweitert und zudem ist
einfach Opferschutz notwendig viele
Politiker stehen im Zentrum der
Aufmerksamkeit ich kann mich nicht
beschweren der Staatsschutz unterstützt
mich hervorragend aber vielen die an der
Basis arbeiten geht es nicht so und da
brauchen wir Unterstützung Strukturen
und auch eine bessere Strafverfolgung
dieser Bedrohung denn der Umfang ist
gewaltig man kann sich gar nicht
vorstellen was da tagtäglich passiert
bei Menschen die sich zum Beispiel
geflüchtete kümmern ja Ulrich in noch
mal in diesem Bereich Demokratie in
unserem Föderalismus beginnt von unten
in den Städten Landkreisen und Gemeinden
und wenn dort sich die Vorfälle häufen
das Stadträte oder BürgermeisterInnen
sich nicht mehr sicher sein können dann
wird damit auch unsere Demokratie
angegriffen und das müssen wir uns vor
Augen führen und ich meine dass hier ein
konzertiertes Vorgehen zwischen
Strafrecht
Aufmerksamkeit in der Gesellschaft aber
auch ganz konkreten Schutz notwendig ist
um die Menschen zu schützen die sich
engagieren aber damit auch insgesamt
demokratisches Engagement zu sichern und
da haben wir ein Thema für das nächste
Jahr ihnen vielen Dank dass Sie bei
diesem mutmaßlich letzten Doppel
Interview bei Phoenix im Bundestag
gebannt
in diesem Jahr sehen bei uns gewesen
sind vielen Dank dafür Ulrich Herr lind
vielen Dank und ihr habt schon gesehen
mit einem Auge die Bundestagspräsidentin
ist schon da gebe ich doch fix mal rein
Wurfs für einen besseren Schutz Hinweis
geben der Personen sowie zur Umsetzung
der Richtlinie zum Schutz von Personen
die Verstöße gegen das Unionsrecht
melden hierzu liegen ein Änderungsantrag
der Fraktion der AFD sowie ein
Entschließungsantrag der Fraktion der
cdu/csu vor für die Aussprache ist eine
Dauer von 39 Minuten vereinbart ich
eröffne die Aussprache und zuerst hat
das Wort für die FDP-Fraktion Stefan
Thome
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren heute bringen wir als Fortis
Koalition zu einem guten Ende war es die
unionsgeführte Vorgängerregierung nicht
mehr in der letzten Wahlperiode
geschafft hat denn eigentlich hätte die
europäische
hinweisgeber-richtlinie bereits bis zum
17.12.2021 also morgen vor einem Jahr
umgesetzt werden müssen und heute
beschließen wir als Deutsche Bundestag
das Gesetz für einen besseren Schutz
Hinweis geben der Personen und schaffen
dadurch endlich mehr Rechtssicherheit
meine Damen und Herren
denn hinweisgeberinnen und Hinweisgeber
leisten einen wichtigen Beitrag zur
Aufdeckung und Handlung von Missständen
und gesetzlichen Verstößen sind aber
bislang oft nur sehr unzureichend
geschützt die allermeisten Unternehmen
handeln natürlich ohnehin nach Recht und
Gesellschaft Arbeitsplätze sorgen für
Wohlstand im Land und sie haben zudem
selbst Interesse daran dass Missstände
im eigenen Unternehmen erkannt und
angezeigt werden um sie selbst
schnellstmöglich zu beheben ein
effektives Meldeverfahren und einen
entsprechendes Compliance Management
sind daher keine Schikane sondern eine
echte Chance für Unternehmen noch besser
zu werden meine Damen und Herren viele
Unternehmen haben das auch schon längst
selbst erkannt und entsprechend
Vorkehrungen getroffen haben bereits
Compliance Abteilungen und Hinweisgeber
Systeme angewandt mit dem heutigen
Gesetz sorgen wir für den notwendigen
Schutz Hinweis geben der Personen ohne
dabei Unternehmen unnötig zu belasten
Rechtssicherheit und Praxis Tauglichkeit
das waren die größten Herausforderungen
bei der Umsetzung der europäischen
Richtlinie der Bundesjustizminister und
sein Haus haben auch der Richtlinie
schon ein sehr sehr gutes Gesetz gemacht
vielen Dank für die Vorarbeiten hierfür
und in der Koalition haben wir den
Entwurf noch einmal intensiv und sehr
konzentriert beraten und noch einigen
Stellen ein paar weitere Verbesserungen
vornehmen können dafür auch mein Dank an
meine britischer Kollegen vieler und
Kollegen Dr Steffen
auch ein paar Punkte die mir wichtig
sind möchte ich jetzt noch kurz eingehen
erstens wir ermöglichen konzernmeldewege
das ist extrem wichtig und in der Sache
auch völlig richtig denn natürlich macht
es Sinn dass in einem Konzern aber auch
bei
ollision wie dem Deutschen Roten Kreuz
nicht jede kleinste Einheiten gerade mal
50 Mitarbeitern eine eigene Meldestelle
einrichten muss es ist doch die Konzern
zentrale die Leitung des ganzen wissen
muss was bei ihren Tochterunternehmen
vor sich geht um hier Abhilfe zu
schaffen
zweitens wir schaffen Anreize dafür dass
sie der Hinweisgeber zunächst an den
internen Meldeweg halten soll denn
eigentliches Ziel ist es doch nicht dass
jemand extern und öffentlich angefangen
hat wird sondern das intern bekannt wird
wir haben bei uns im Unternehmen
Missstände und die wollen wir selbst
abstellen 3 wir sehen nun vor dass auch
anonyme Meldungen bearbeitet werden
müssen und zwar nicht nachrangig zur
nicht anonymen Meldungen denn es macht
doch keinen Sinn wenn Unternehmen zum
Beispiel auf anonymen Wege von
gravierenden Missständen kennt das aber
zurückstellen muss weil andere nicht an
dem Gemälde Bagatellen zunächst einmal
bearbeitet werden müssen
und viertens gerade nach den Erkenntnis
über rechtsextreme chatgruppen in
Behörden ohne Zusammenhang mit den
Razzien in reichsbürgerszene ist es doch
absolut richtig das Hinweisgeber auch
geschützt werden müssen wenn sie
Verstöße gegen die Pflicht zur
Verfassungstreue in Behörden melden
Extremisten Reichsbürger Faschisten
Neonazis haben unter Behörden einfach
nichts verloren meine Damen und Herren
und lassen Sie mich abschließend noch
Stellung nehmen zum einigen
Befürchtungen die in der Öffentlichkeit
geführt worden sind erstens das
hinweisgeberschutz fördert kein
Denunziantentum es führt auch keinen
Generalverdacht gegen Unternehmen viel
mehr schafft das Gesetz die rechtlichen
Voraussetzungen dafür dass zunächst
unter dem selbst von Fehlentwicklungen
und Missständen Kenntnis erhalten und
selber die Möglichkeit haben diese
Missstände abzustellen der
hinweisgeberschutz greift auch dann
nicht wenn jemand bewusst
Falschmeldungen nach außen geben und die
Unternehmen selber sagen uns doch wir
gehen ja ohnehin allen Hinweisen nach
völlig egal ob sie im Anwendungsbereich
des Gesetzes liegen oder oder außerhalb
denn für uns Unternehmen ist einzige
entscheidend um sich um substanzierte
Hinweise handelt deshalb und das ist
auch noch ein abschließendes Wort an die
Union was ich mir gewünscht hätte das
wäre wenn die Union dieses Vorhaben
konstruktiver positive begleitet hätte
denn wir bringen hier zu Ende was sie in
jeder Zeit nicht geschafft haben schade
dass wir auf ihr Hilfe nicht vertrauen
konnten aber mein Dank an den
Justizminister an das Ministerium und an
die Kolleginnen und Kollegen der anderen
Fraktion der Koalition für die wertvolle
Mitarbeit bedanke mich und freue mich
dass wir dieses Gesetz verabschieden
können
nächster Redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
DR Martin Plum
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die heutige
Debatte bietet einen guten Anlass mit
einigen Aussagen aus dem Reich der
Märchen sagen und Fabelwelt aufzuräumen
ausgesprochen oder geschrieben haben sie
nicht etwa die Gebrüder Grimm sondern
die Brüder und Schwestern
ampelkoalitionäre erste Aussage wir
setzen die
eu-wistelbohrerrichtlinie rechtssicher
und praktikabel um dieses struktursa
findet sich in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag
der vorliegende Gesetzentwurf ist weder
das eine noch das andere er wimmelt vor
unbestimmten Rechtsbegriffen erklärt
sein Verhältnis zu bestehenden
meldesystemen etwa nach dem Lieferketten
sorgfaltspflichtgesetz nicht er schafft
keinerlei Anreize für die sinnvolle
Nutzung interner Meldewege Aufgaben und
Befugnisse der Meldestelle bleiben
schwammig das Verhältnis der externen
Meldestellen zu anderen Behörden bleibt
unsicher das ist praktikabel und das ist
dann Summe ein großes
Beschäftigungsprogramm für unsere
ohnehin überlasteten Gerichte
zweite Aussage
hinweisgeberschutz ist
Unternehmensschutz drei Mal haben sie
lieber Herr Bundesminister Buschmann
diese drei Worte in der ersten Beratung
des Gesetzentwurfs am 29 September
gesagt dreimal zu viel denn das
Gegenteil ist der Fall 90.000
Unternehmen in unserem Land belasten sie
durch dieses Gesetz mit zusätzlichen
Kosten und neuer Bürokratie und schenken
ihnen noch nicht mal einen Wein ein sie
haben hier am 29 September behauptet ich
zitiere 70% der Großunternehmen und etwa
40% der KMU hätten heute schon
Meldestellen eine Studie vom 22
September eine Woche zuvor kommt zu
einem ganz anderen Ergebnis
19% der Unternehmen haben danach gerade
mal Hinweisgebersysteme vollständig
implementiert die kleinen und
mittelständischen Unternehmen in ihren
Wahlkreisen werden sich sicher über
dieses Weihnachtsgeschenk in ihrem
Hausaufgabenheft freuen lieber
ampelkoalitionäre
dritte Aussage wir nutzen alle
flexibilitätsspielräume der Richtlinie
aus auch das haben sie lieber Herr
Bundesminister Buschmann hier am 29
September gesagt und das führt ihre
Koalition mit ihren Änderungsanträgen
jetzt endgültig hat absurdung während
die Richtlinie die Entscheidung ob
anonyme Meldungen möglich sind den
Mitgliedstaaten überlässt satteln sie an
diesem Punkt munter drauf sie
entscheiden sich nicht nur für anonyme
Meldungen sondern verpflichten 90.000
Unternehmen in unserem Land künftig dazu
anonyme meldekanäle einzurichten und sie
tun das im vollen Bewusstsein dass damit
zusätzliche Kosten und Belastungen für
die Unternehmen verbunden sind in der
Begründung ihrer Änderungsanträge heißt
es anonyme meldekanäle ich zitiere sind
mit Zusatzkosten für die notwendigen
technischen Vorrichtungen oder die
Einschaltung einer Ombudsperson
verbunden so wie mit einer zusätzlichen
Belastung durch den erhöhten Aufwand für
die Einrichtung der Meldestellen
erklären sie auch das gerne mal
persönlich in ihren Wahlkreisen und vor
allem hätte sagen Sie dann bitte auch
dass das keine unnötige Bürokratie für
unsere Unternehmen ist
vierte Aussage uns ist es gelungen die
Rechtsansicht der Kommission zum Wohle
der Unternehmen zu ändern auch das haben
sie lieber Herr Bundesminister Buschmann
hier am 29 September gesagt fragt man
ihr Ministerium welche konkreten
Änderungen das denn sein sollen herrscht
Schweigen in Wald in der Antwort auf
meine Frage heißt sie sich zitiere
wieder das Bundesministerium der Justiz
nimmt regelmäßig an den Treffen einer
Expertengruppe teil und bringt doch
seine Rechtsansichten ein Aha von
Änderungen zum Bruder der Unternehmen
keine Spur fragt man dann gezielt nach
der von Ihnen ausdrücklich in Bezug
genommen konzernlösung wieder Schweigen
im Wald ich zitiere der Austausch mit
der Kommission zu dieser Frage ist noch
nicht abgeschlossen aha von Änderungen
zum Wohle der Unternehmen keine Spur
fakt ist damit die sinnvolle
konzernlösung ist bis heute nicht
europarechtlich abgesichert und sie
lassen alle Konzerne Unternehmen damit
im Regen der Rechtsunsicherheit stehen
fünfte Aussage es wird sorgfältig darauf
geachtet dass während der Krise keine
unverhältnismäßigen zusätzlichen
Bürokratielasten die Wirtschaft
beeinträchtigen
das haben sie lieber Herr Bundesminister
Buschmann ausnahmsweise einmal nicht in
der ersten Beratung gesagt es stammt
aber vom selben Tag es ist ihr groß
postuliertes belastungsmoratorium dass
sie das mit diesem Gesetz vollkommen
absurdum führen dürfte inzwischen jeden
hier im Saat klar geworden sein aber
gerne noch ein paar 90.000 Unternehmen
in unserem Land lassen sie schon nach
der ursprünglichen Begründung ihres
Gesetzentwurfs mit einmaligen Kosten von
rund 200 Millionen Euro und Folgekosten
von weiteren 200 Millionen Euro Jahr für
Jahr legt man realistischere
Berechnungen zugrunde sind es sogar 400
Millionen Euro Jahr für Jahr und die
Zusatzkosten durch ihre Änderungsanträge
kommen noch an top fast eine halbe
Milliarde Euro stellen Sie unseren
Unternehmen damit jedes Jahr in Rechnung
stellen Sie diese Rechnungen bitte vor
Weihnachten persönlich an die
betroffenen Unternehmen in ihren
Wahlkreisen zu
Fazit ihre Koalition verbindet nur ein
Motto mehr Bürokratie Wagen das ist die
Formel auf die sie sich immer wieder
gerne und genüsslich einigen und das
zeigt eines deutlich sie sind keine
Regierungskoalition sie sind eine
regulierungskoalition
nächster Redner für die SPD-Fraktion
Sebastian Fiedler
[Applaus]
liebe Frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen Liebe interessierte das ist
eigentlich eine ganz gute Gelegenheit
ein paar Dinge noch mal zurech zurück
Rücken und sozusagen das Gesamtbild noch
einmal zu schärfen denn es ist ja so wir
stehen ja heute erst hier deswegen weil
in der letzten Legislatur mit der Union
leider nichts hingekriegt worden ist wir
hätten eigentlich ein Gesetz schon vor
anderthalb Jahren haben können wenn das
mit ihnen gegangen wäre dazu habe ich
aber von ihnen irgendwie gar nichts
gehört Bürokratie war das Hauptthema
ich finde wir haben ganz gutes Gesetz
hingekriegt es gibt mir aber die
Gelegenheit das noch einmal auch für
alle Interessierten die sich nicht mit
allen Details beschäftigt haben ist in
den gesamten gesellschaftlichen Rahmen
einzuordnen ich glaube das ist nämlich
wichtig denn man muss erklären wir haben
uns in der Gesellschaft gewissen Normen
und Werten verschrieben
Gesetze kommen demokratisch Zustande
normengerechtes Verhalten der
Menschenrecht dazu bei dass wir im
gesellschaftlichen Frieden leben können
und das ist eigentlich so etwas was
insgesamt glaube ich ja zu selten
diskutiert wird wir sprechen viel über
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt und das
eine hat hier glaube ich schon sehr sehr
viel miteinander zu tun denn wir haben
wir haben ganz viele regulative in der
Gesellschaft wir haben das im ganz
kleinen in der Familie dann nennt man
das Erziehung wenn Verstöße gegen Normen
passieren wir haben das in
Organisationsformen wir kennen
schiedsgerichtete bei Parteien oder bei
Vereinen und wir kennen das auch hier im
Raum die Frau Präsidentin kann
Ordnungsmaßnahmen erlassen und ich bin
heute ehrlich gesagt ganz froh dass
nicht vor 50 Jahren Rede weil wie ich
gehört habe vor 50 Jahren hätte ich
heute einen ordnungshof gekriegt weil
ich keine Krawatte trage also es ist
offenbar so Normen und Werte ändern sich
auch warum ich das alles erzähle
tatsächlich das ist deswegen wichtig
weil ich glaube wir müssen das noch mal
herausärfen es gibt eben bestimmte
Normen und Werte der ist ja Unrecht
Gehalt so hoch dass wir sagen wir haben
da Ordnungswidrigkeiten Straftaten
Bestände definiert wir haben das
Gewaltmonopol des Staates also die
staatlichen Organisationen damit betraut
diese entsprechend zu ahnen aber der
Punkt über den wir heute sprechen ist
die Frage der Aufdeckung also wie kommt
es eigentlich überhaupt zur Aufdeckung
solcher Normen und Werte und es ist eben
wichtig dass diese Aufdeckung aus der
Gesellschaft herauskommt weil wir eben
gerade nicht dass dem Gewaltmonopol
überlassen wollen dann wären wir in
einem Überwachungsstaat sowie in China
und das wollen wir gerade eben alle
nicht
und wenn wir jetzt über Hinweisgeber
sprechen wisselbauer der englische
Begriff dann ist das etwas aus der
Normalität der Gesellschaft aus der
Normalität des Alltags eine Zahl etwa 90
Prozent der Strafverfahren die bei der
Polizei bearbeitet werden kommen nur
deswegen zustande weil es anzeigen und
Hinweise gibt nicht etwa weil die
Ermittlungsbehörden etwas aufgedeckt
haben und die größten Skandal über die
wir zu diskutieren hatten paar
Stichworte Panama papers Paradise papers
Lux leaks Swiss secrets also die größten
Steuerdaten unserer Genosse Norbert
Walter Bauer singen was das entsprechend
bedeutet die kommen da gibt es mehr
Erfolge zu verzeichnen als die größten
internationalen
strafverfolgungsermittlung überhaupt zu
Tage befördert hatten und deswegen ist
es sehr wichtig und wir sollten die
Gelegenheit nutzen und lieber dr Plum
dazu haben sie keine Silbe verloren das
ist eben diesen mutigen Menschen und der
Courage dieser Menschen zu verdanken ist
sie genießen unseren Respekt und unsere
Anerkennung unseren allerhöchsten Dank
und ihnen gebührt ein großer Applaus an
der Stelle sie haben nur über Bürokratie
geredet keine Silbe darüber wecken
wertvollen Beitrag hinweisgeberinnen und
Hinweisgeber hinterlassen und wir müssen
deswegen ein Gesetz machen weil es eben
Schwächen gibt weil es immer mal wieder
passiert dass hinweisgebenden Personen
Repressalien drohen sie werden zu
Unrecht entlassen aus dem Unternehmen
und deswegen geht es im Prinzip in
diesem Gesetz um zweierlei Dinge auf der
einen Seite schützen wir hinweisgebende
Personen vor Repressalien und auf der
anderen Seite verpflichten wir
Organisationen dazu entsprechende
Stellen einzurichten die professionell
mit diesen Hinweisen umgehen können das
ist ein wichtiger Punkt und im Übrigen
muss dem Bundesjustizminister
selbstverständlich Recht geben die
Aufdeckung
unternehmensintern solcher Themen und
solcher Korruptionsverfahren oder
ähnlicher Straftaten die natürlich der
Wirtschaft und geschützt die Wirtschaft
und es verhindert größere Skandale das
ist doch außerordentlich klar eigentlich
finde ich
und Liebe Union das hätten wir alles
schon haben können Christine Lambrecht
hatte ein sehr guten Vorschlag gemacht
und hatte schon Kompromisse vorgelegt
aber sie wollten nur eine Eins zu Eins
Umsetzung der EU-Regeln das hätte dazu
geführt dass selbstmeldungen zu
Straftaten zu Dingen die wir hier als
besonders verwerflich erachten nicht zum
Schutz von Hinweis gebenden Personen
geführt hatten sie machen da offenbar
nach meiner Einschätzung ein paar
Denkfehler deswegen ist es gut dass auch
das drucksche Gesetz dazu beigetragen
hat dass gerade auch anonyme Meldungen
jetzt hier verpflichtend bearbeiten
werden müssen wenn sie sich mit
Unternehmensvertretern unterhalten
hätten hätten Sie gewusst dass sie
sowieso dort bearbeitet werden in den
Meldungen es gibt zahlreiche andere
rechtliche Hintergründe warum das mit
allen Unternehmen also mit wirklich
vermitteln Mittelständler ich weiß nicht
wo sie unterwegs gewesen waren sie haben
vielleicht nur in die Argumente der
alten Legislatur geguckt aber sich nicht
mit Praktikern unterhalten das haben wir
getan wir haben sehr viel Arbeit
investiert
und wir schützen und das hat der Kollege
Thomi zu Recht gesagt gerade in diesen
Tagen natürlich auch und das hätten sie
schon dreimal nicht gewollt auch
hinweisgebende personen die Hinweise auf
verfassungs- und Treue Beamte geben also
muss das tatsächlich ernsthaft noch
erklären in diesen Tagen warum das von
Bedeutung ist dass wir Staatsdiener ein
Uniform die einen Herr Brandner dass sie
sich trauen angesichts dieser Themen
hier überhaupt den Mund aufzumachen das
gehört schon da gehört schon wirklich
Mut und Orange zu sie sind doch
Brandstifter Nomen ist oben kann ich nur
sagen ohne
ohne ihren Rechte Grundlage hätten wir
diese ganzen verschwörungsextremisten
wahrscheinlich gar nicht so sie sind
Hass und Hetze genau aus dieser Fraktion
hören wir hier jeden Tag im Plenum also
halten sich lieber ein bisschen zurück
es ist an der Stelle gut und richtig
dass wir genau hin was gebende Personen
schützen die Hinweise auf Beamte geben
die auf die sie abzielen mit ihren
Rechten Strategien und es ist deswegen
auch wichtig weil wir das Vertrauen in
die Sicherheitsbehörden stärken müssen
das Vertrauen in sicherheitsbündnis
außerordentlich gut aber es sind
Durchschnittswerte und man muss mal
sagen wenn sie sich in Stadtteile
begeben wo Menschen leben deren
Einwanderungsgeschichte aus anderen
Ländern kommt oder deren Familie ist das
Vertrauen die Sicherheitsbehörden
deswegen nicht gut und deswegen ist es
eines von vielen Maßnahmen und
Mosaikstein wo wir sagen wir stärken
hier das Vertrauen in die
Sicherheitsbehörden das ist im Interesse
der Sicherheitsbehörden lassen sich das
ausgerechnet von mir gesagt werden das
ist wichtig und deswegen müssen wir auch
diesen Teil schützen den hätten sie nie
mitgemacht in der Vergangenheit das ist
ein gutes Gesetz stimmen Sie dem zu dann
tun Sie etwas Gutes Glück auf schöne
Feiertage
sagt Sebastian Fiedler aus der
SPD-Fraktion wo er Sprecher der AG
Kriminalpolitik ist und er war vor
seiner Zeit im Deutschen Bundestag auch
eines der führenden Kräfte im Bund
Deutscher
Kriminalbeamter nächster Redner aus der
afd-fraktion Fabian Jacobi
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
wir behandeln den Entwurf der
Bundesregierung für ein Hinweisgeber
Schutzgesetz diese Stichwort findet sich
auch im Wahlprogramm der AFD dort heißt
es Zitat es bleiben oftmals nur noch
alternative Medien und Whistleblower zur
Aufdeckung und Offenlegung
regierungsamtlichen Unrechts auf diesem
Grund sind anonyme Hinweisgeber zur
Aufdeckung von Korruption
Machtmissbrauch und Straftaten und
verzichtbar sie da Ende wir stehen also
dem Gedanken des hinweisgeberschutzes
nicht nur offen gegenüber sondern
fordern diesen ausdrücklich ein dennoch
werden wir dieses Gesetz gleich ablehnen
wie passt das zusammen wenn wir von
Hinweisgeber Schutz sprechen dann stehen
uns Personen wie Julian Assange oder
Edward Snowden vor Augen jene die aus
dem Inneren Leviathans Dinge ans Licht
holen von denen die mächtigen nicht
wollen dass sie gesehen werden um die
geht es bei diesem Gesetz hier aber eher
nicht angesprochen ist hier der normale
Mitarbeiter irgendein Unternehmens der
Dinge melden soll Vorgänge in seinem
Unternehmen zunächst einmal
rechtswidrige Vorgänge also
Gesetzesverstöße so weit so gut dann
aber eben auch Dinge die gerade nicht
rechtswidrig sind im Umkehrschluss also
legal sind die aber dem Ziel
irgendwelcher Vorschriften widersprechen
da wird es dann schon mulmig denn das
bedeutet dass man wenn etwa die
herrschenden Parteien hier neue Gesetze
machen sich nicht nur an das halten soll
was diese Gesetze explizit vorschreiben
sondern auch erspüren muss was
vielleicht noch alles dem Ziel eines
Gesetzes zu widerlaufen könnte
anderenfalls man gewertigen muss
gemeldet und gegebenenfalls
sanktionsfrei öffentlich angeprangert zu
werden da bekommt dieses Gesetz ganz
schnell eine ganz andere Tendenz nämlich
die einer allgemeinen gegenseitigen
Überwachung der Bürger ob der andere ob
der Arbeitgeber auch brav den Zielen der
Regierung folgt
besonders hervorgehoben wird der Bereich
des Steuerrechts da sollen nicht nur
strafbare Dinge also Steuerhinterziehung
gemeldet werden sondern jeglicher
Verstoß gegen steuerliche Vorschriften
oder wiederum gegen das Ziel
steuerlicher Vorschriften sieht man dann
noch dass das Gesetz zwar die
Verschwiegenheitspflichten der Ärzte und
der Rechtsanwälte berücksichtigt aber
die Verschwiegenheitspflicht der
Steuerberater und ihrer Mitarbeiter ganz
bewusst nicht einbezieht dann hört man
die sprichwörtliche Nachtigall hier
recht laut trapsen
aber nun mit den aufdeckern von
Korruption und Machtmissbrauch aus dem
Inneren des Staates sind die wenigstens
auch gemeint von diesem Gesetz nicht
wirklich denn eine staatliche Stelle
muss etwas nur zur Verschlusssache
erklären und schon ist dieses Gesetz
darauf nicht mehr anwendbar gleichwohl
er fährt auch der innerstaatliche
Bereich Aufmerksamkeit offenbar in der
Annahme dass die Gelegenheit angesichts
der aktuellen dramatischen Berichte über
sogenannte Reichsbürger gerade günstig
sei wurde im Ausschuss noch ein Passus
eingefügt Staatsbedienstete sollen
danach insbesondere Meldung machen wenn
ihre Kollegen etwas äußern das gegen die
Pflicht zur Verfassungstreue verstößt
dagegen wären nun gar nichts zu sagen
solange ist dabei um das herkömmliche
Verständnis von Verfassungstreue und
spiegelbildlich Verfassungsfeindlichkeit
ginge also um die Abschaffung von
Demokratie und Rechtsstaat das Menschen
die solches befürworten auf dem
Staatsdienst entfernt werden müssen das
unterliegt ja gar keinem Zweifel leider
aber leben wir in Zeiten in denen dieses
überkommene Verständnis von
Verfassungstreue zunehmend überlagert
wird von einem neuen Verständnis wonach
schon die Kritik an den Inhabern
staatlicher Ämter den Staat selbst die
legitimieren und damit
verfassungsfeindlich sein soll und damit
bekommt das Gesetz auch hier einen ganz
ominösen Beigeschmack das Sahnehäubchen
ist dann der beigestellte
Entschließungsantrag der
koalitionsfraktion in dem unter anderem
von finanziellen Vergünstigungen die
Rede ist also von milde Prämien das
wächst dann Erinnerungen an einen
anderen Staat und eine andere
Gesellschaftsordnung von der wir
annahmen sie seien 1990 auf den
Müllhaufen der Geschichte geflogen
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
nächster Redner für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen dr tilstedt und Till
Steffen ist einer der Parlamentarischen
Geschäftsführer der Fraktion Bündnis 90
die Grünen
Gerte frau Präsidentin meine Damen und
Herren nach dieser sehr verschwurbelten
Rede geht es glaube ich noch mal darum
ist es an der Zeit auch noch mal
deutlich zu machen worum es bei diesem
Gesetz wirklich geht es geht darum dass
es viele große Skandale gibt wirklich
mit großen Ausmaß die ohne
hinweisgeberinnen oder Hinweisgeber von
innen niemals ans Tageslicht gekommen
wären und es sind ja schon einige
Beispiele von Sebastian Fiedler genannt
worden nehmen wir das Thema cumex
südlicher ein ein Bereich wo ein großen
Umfang der größte steuerraub unserer
Geschichte wie viele gesagt haben also
sowas ist nur ins Tageslicht gekommen
weil irgendjemand irgendwann von innen
gesagt hat hier passiert etwas wo ganz
gezielt Steuern hinterzogen werden
sollen sich sehr trickreiche
Gestaltungen im Umgang mit der Steuer
und man sieht ja es ist gar keine
Bagatelle derjenige der das ganze
erfunden hat hallo Berge als er die Tage
zu acht Jahren Freiheit verurteilt
worden das was am Ende steht das Wirken
von Strafgerichten mit entscheiden mit
einschneidenden Sanktionen das ist das
was am Ende steht was am Anfang steht
ist der Hinweis von Menschen die
tatsächlich wissen was innen passiert
und einen entsprechenden Hinweis geben
können und überhaupt solche Ermittlungen
anstoßen können damit dann tatsächlich
entsprechend der Stadt handeln kann und
worum geht es also im Kern es geht darum
ob das was wir hier im Deutschen
Bundestag an Gesetzen beschließen ob das
für alle gilt oder ob das nicht gilt für
Leute die einfach nur mit ausreichend
großen Beträgen hantieren oder die genug
Ressourcen haben um ihr kriminelles
Handeln so zu verschleiern mit ganz
komplizierten Konstruktionen während der
einzelne einfache Gewerbetreibende
jederzeit das Finanzamt hat es geht also
wirklich um Gerechtigkeit es geht um die
Frage ob unser Rechtstaat wirklich für
alle gilt und deswegen müssen wir ein
großes Interesse daran haben dieses
Gesetz in der wirksamen Weise auch
angewendet wird
und tatsächlich was ist ja auch ganz
wichtig ist ist dass wir eingefügt haben
das verfassungsfeindliche Äußerungen von
Beamten und Beamten auch zum Gegenstand
von Hinweisen gemacht werden können sehr
ganz klar
Polizistinnen Polizisten sie leisten sie
leisten ein Eid auf das Grundgesetz auf
unsere Verfassung und wenn dann ein
Polizeibeamter sagt irgendwie kommt mir
das hier komisch vor hier reden in einer
Weise Kolleginnen und Kollegen die mit
der Verfassung nicht vereinbar sind zum
Beispiel rassistische Äußerungen die
natürlich die Sorge begründet erscheinen
lassen dass das sich auch im
polizeilichen Handeln niederschlägt dass
dieser Beamte dann bescheid sagt und
dafür sorgt dass dem entgegengewirkt
wird im frühen Stadium ist absolut
richtig und das macht ja auch die Razzia
deutlich lieber vor wenigen Tagen hatten
wollen wir wirklich so lange warten bis
tatsächlich Leute Dienstwaffen entwenden
und sich gegen den Staat wenden oder
wollen wir früher intervenieren ich wäre
eindeutig für letzte ist
ganz wichtiger Bereich wo Whistleblowing
auch eine große Rolle spielt beim Thema
Tierschutz wir haben es ja erlebt in
Zeiten von Corona wo tatsächlich in
großen Fleischfabriken die
corona-auflagen missachtet wurden
Menschen zu Schaden kamen weil
tatsächlich entsprechende Vorkehrungen
nicht eingehalten wurden da muss
natürlich zum Schutz der
MitarbeiterInnen Mitarbeiter die der
harte Arbeit leisten es möglich sein
hinzuweisen ohne dass das einschneidende
persönliche Konsequenzen hat und wir
haben einen weiteren Punkt hier an der
Stelle ergänzt wir haben es eben auch
ermöglicht dass Tierärzte die im
gewerblichen Bereich tätig sind dass die
auch darauf hinweisen können wir haben
vor wenigen Wochen darüber gesprochen
über die massenhafte Vergabe von
Antibiotika und da ist ja die Frage wie
soll das denn eigentlich bekannt werden
außer durch einen Tierarzt der natürlich
weiß was eine vernünftige Gabe von
Antibiotika ist und was tatsächlich
unvernünftig ist und dass da darauf
hingewiesen werden kann ist auch ein
wichtiger Schritt den wir durch dieses
Gesetz machen
und weiß ja auch einer der Punkte ist
die angesprochen wurden wir haben sehr
ausführlich mit Unternehmen gesprochen
von mit Compliance Stellen von großen
Unternehmen mit der Telekom mit
ThyssenKrupp mit Aurubis in Hamburg habe
ich gesprochen und die haben ganz klar
gesagt natürlich bearbeiten wir auch
anonyme hin weil sie werden ja schön
blöd natürlich wollen wir Missständen
auf den Grund gehen und manchmal sind
die anonymen Hinweise gerade die
interessantesten und alle haben gesagt
wenn man sich für die Bearbeitung dieser
Vorgänge sinnvollerweise eine
entsprechende Software zulegt dann bitte
schon das Standardprodukt die
Möglichkeit noch anonyme Hinweise zu
verarbeiten also ihr Argument von
Mehrkosten kann ich an der Stelle nicht
nachvollziehen es gibt ein paar Punkte
es gibt ein paar Punkte die wir in
diesem Gesetz noch nicht ausreichend
abgebildet haben nach meiner Meinung
nach das ist die Frage ob auch Meldung
von Verstößen gegen das Allgemeine
Gleichbehandlungsgesetz ausreichend
abgebildet sind das wird im
Entschließungsantrag entsprechend noch
mal verfolgt und wir haben durchaus auch
Fälle wo es Meldungen geben kann aus dem
öffentlichen Interesse die im
öffentlichen Interesse legen die wir
auch nicht unbedingt ausreichend
abgebildet haben also etwa das Beispiel
von Brigitte Heinisch der Berliner
whistleblowerin die auf Missstände in
Pflegeheimen hinwies aber es ist ein
großer Schritt wir machen einen großen
Schritt nach vorne für den Schutz von
hinweisgeberinnen
letzten Wahlperiode die cdu/csu
erfolgreich diesen Schritt ausgesessen
hat und deswegen finde ich ihre Kritik
hier auch sehr sehr kleinteilig ich
finde bedauerlich dass der Bundesrat das
heute nicht aufgesetzt hat aber wir
werden natürlich dieses Gesetz auch
durchsetzen und das ist auch notwendig
zum Schutz von hinweisgeberinnen
Hinweisgebern und noch viel wichtiger
zum Schutz unseres Rechtsstaats und zur
gleichmäßigen Durchsetzung von Gesetzen
für alle vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
till steffen war das für die Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen der Bundestag
diskutiert noch mal über einen
Gesetzentwurf der Bundesregierung zum
besseren Schutz für Whistleblower oder
wie es hier heißt Hinweis gebende
Personen es geht auch um die Umsetzung
einer EU-Richtlinie die
koalitionsvertragsfraktionen haben
allerlei Änderungen Vorschläge
eingebracht in diesem Gesetzentwurf
unter anderem in Hinblick auf Hinweise
auf Reichsbürger beispielsweise in der
Polizei steht steffen hat es eben
erwähnt Clara Bünger ist am Pool für die
Linksfraktion leider
digital weil er ohne die Gefahr der
Auslieferung in die USA wo eben eine
hohe Strafe droht nicht nach Deutschland
reisen konnte für mich war sein Handeln
damals sehr beeindruckend als er im
Jahre 2013 die weltweite
massenüberwachung durch die NSA
aufdeckte und mit seinen Enthüllungen
das Ausmaß der überwachungs- und
spionagepraktiken von US-Geheimdiensten
der Öffentlichkeit zugänglich machte
denn nur durch diese Kenntnis und das
haben sie auch gesagt Herr Fiedler nur
durch diese Kenntnis und durch die
geliebten Informationen war es möglich
eine Diskussion eine breite Diskussion
in der Gesellschaft zu führen und ich
finde es ein Riesenskandal Herr Jakobi
dass sie den Namen etwas snoten auch nur
in den Mund nehmen und für ihre Hechte
Hetze verwenden das ist wirklich ein
Riesenskandal
schämen sie sich wenn er das wüsste er
würde nie ein Wort mit ihnen wechseln
bei vielen Menschen auch bei mir hat
seinen Mut sein Wissen über die massiven
Eingriffe in Grundrechte und diese mit
der Welt zu teilen und dabei seine
eigene Freiheit aufs Spiel zu setzen er
hat seine eigene freiheits-gesetz sehr
bewegt und ein immensen Eindruck bei mir
hinterlassen
whistleblowerin verdienen unsere
Anerkennung und unseren Schutz weil sie
nicht weil sie eben nicht zu ihrem
eigenen Vorteil Missstände aufdecken
sondern weil sie für unsere Demokratie
und unsere Rechtsstaatlichkeit tun und
davon und die ohne dieses insider wissen
während viele Straftaten und Skandale
niemals aufgedeckt worden die EU Wissen
Hinweisgeber Richtlinie wird nun endlich
ein Jahr nach Ablauf der Frist in
nationales Recht umgesetzt das ist gut
und das begrüßen wir auch
dennoch gibt es einige Punkte einige
Punkte wurden durch die Sachverständigen
Anhörung aufgenommen das ist gut wie zum
Beispiel die Pflicht zur Bearbeitung
anonymer Meldung wurde aufgenommen
erhebliche Lücken bestehen aber
weiterhin im staatlichen Bereich zwar
können jetzt auch Verstöße von Beamten
gegen die verfassungsfreulich gemeldet
werden das ist richtig und gerade nach
der reichsburger Razzia es wurde gesagt
auch dringend notwendig der Entwurf
versagt aber gerade bei wissen denn ein
deutscher Edward Snowden wäre nach dem
geplanten Gesetz nicht geschützt denn
Geheimdienste sind komplett ausgenommen
und Behörden können Hinweise einfach
unter den Teppich Kern indem sie es
Verschluss Sache einstufen dabei wäre
das doch ein wichtiger Schritt Herr
Fiedler wenn Sie auch hier diese Person
uns Situationen mit einbeziehen würden
das Gesetz schützt außerdem nur bei
bestimmten Rechtsverstößen Hinweise auf
sonstige Fehlverhalten die
Machtmissbrauch oder Verstöße gegen das
Allgemeine Gleichbehandlungsgesetz sind
weiterhin nicht erfasst sie haben es
selbst angemerkt dabei steht es auch so
in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag und wir
würden uns wünschen dass sie da wirklich
zeitnah nachbessern der
Entschließungsantrag
[Applaus]
wird zwar auch diese müssen jetzt aber
auch erstellten schnell umgesetzt werden
klarer Dünger Sprecherin für
Rechtspolitik in der Linksfraktion
kritisiert das Whistleblower in
Nachrichtendienste von einer besseren
Schutz ausgenommen seien in diesem neuen
Gesetz das nachher verabschiedet werden
wird von der Mehrheit der
Ampelkoalition kamen Weg jetzt für die
SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren der
dieselskandal im Automobilsektor die
bilanzmanipulation des wirecard-konzerns
diese wirtschaftskandale aus der
jüngsten Zeit hätten wahrscheinlich
verhindert werden können wenn Staat und
Öffentlichkeit nur rechtzeitig über das
notwendige Insiderwissen verfügt hätten
Insiderwissen das vor allem die
Beschäftigten dieser Unternehmen haben
aber warum haben sie ihr Wissen nicht
geteilt ganz einfach
Hinweisgeber in werden in ihren
Unternehmen drangsaliert gekündigt und
müssen um ihre wirtschaftliche Existenz
fürchten dem schieben wir nun einen
Riegel vor
mit dem hinweisgeberschutzgesetz
schlagen wir ein neues Kapitel im Schutz
von Whistleblower innen auf im
Gesetzgebungsverfahren haben wir hart
gerungen und wir haben viel Gutes
erreicht ich möchte drei Erfolge nennen
erstens wir haben ein eigenes
hinweisgeberschutzgesetz wir hätten die
EU-Richtlinie auch durch Änderungen
mehrere einzelgesetze umsetzen können
aber wir wollten Rechtssicherheit für
Whistleblower in wenn sie noch zögern
ein Missstand öffentlich zu machen
sollen sie in nur ein Gesetz schauen
müssen dann wissen Sie was für sie gilt
zweitens wir schützen Menschen die
Verstöße auch gegen nationales Recht
Anzeigen laut Richtlinie hätten wir den
Schutz der Düsseldorfer in nur einführen
müssen wenn die Person Verstöße gegen EU
Recht melden also zum Beispiel Verstöße
gegen das Datenschutzrecht dieser Schutz
hätte viele Lücken gelassen so jedoch
wird Hinweis gebenden Personen mehr
richtig Sicherheit gegeben mein Kollege
Sebastian Fiedler hat das schon
ausgeführt und drittens nicht zuletzt
haben wir in den Ver Planung einen neuen
Schutzbereich für Beamtinnen geschaffen
das wurde heute auch schon häufiger
gesagt Beamtin sind nun
verdienstrechtlichen Konsequenzen
geschützt wenn Sie Hinweise auf
Äußerungen von Kolleginnen melden die an
deren Pflicht zur Verfassungstreue
zweifeln lassen das können insbesondere
auch Nachrichten oder Bilder in
chatgruppen sein in denen Beamten
umstutzfantasien und staatsfeindlichkeit
äußern leider sind solche chatgruppen
kein Einzelfall umso wichtiger ist es
dass wir davon erfahren
mit heute hat der alte korbsgeist also
ausgedient wenn es um die Treue zur
Verfassung geht stattdessen stehen die
Demokratin wieder einmal geschlossen
zusammen mit der heutigen Verabschiedung
des hinweisgeberschutzgesetzes ist
unsere Arbeit als Gesetzgeber aber noch
nicht fertig unsere Entschließungsantrag
macht sehr deutlich an welchen Bereichen
wir in künftigen Gesetzen weiter
arbeiten wollen um den Schutz von Wissen
blauer in weiter zu stärken auch hier
möchte ich drei Punkte nennen ersten
Staatsgeheimnisse wir wollen den
hinweisgeberschutz in den Bereichen der
nationalen Sicherheit der
Nachrichtendienste der werbeauftragten
und im Bereich der Verschluss Sachen
modernisieren gerade hier ist die
Abwägung zwischen dem
aufdeckungsinteresse und dem Schutz der
nationalen Sicherheit besonders heikel
das stimmt schon trotzdem müssen wir
diese Abwägung vornehmen und
hinweisgeberinnen unter festen
schutzstellen zweitens im Bereich der
verschlussachen wollen wir prüfen wie
wir zügig eine unabhängige
Kontrollinstanz aufbauen die für zwei
Fragen Hinsicht der hinsichtlich der
materiellen Einstufung von
Verschlusssachen zuständig ist dies wird
auch im Hinblick auf das neue
bundesdaten
bundesstransparenzgesetz wichtig sein
drittens nicht zuletzt werden wir
beobachten ob hinreichend gewährleistet
ist das hinweisgebende Personen bei der
Meldung von Verstößen gegen das
Allgemeine Gleichbehandlungsgesetz
geschützt sind genauso wenn sie
sonstiges erhebliches Fehlverhalten
melden dessen Aufdeckung in besonderen
öffentlichen Interesse liegt
ich will abschließend ganz deutlich
werden wer die Hinweisgeber in als den
sozial in verunglimpft hat noch nichts
verstanden wisselblauer in leisten einen
Dienst an unserer Gesellschaft ihnen
rufe ich zu Hartmut der Staat wird euren
Mut von heute an schützen vielen Dank
aus der SPD-Fraktion war die vorletzte
Rednerin in dieser Debatte die letzte
jetzt Susanne hürl aus der
Unionsfraktion die Unionsfraktion hat
einen Entschließungsantrag eingebracht
nicht ganz unwahrscheinlich dass Susanne
hier den einen und anderen Satz dazu
noch sagen wird jetzt
sehr geehrte
Frau Kollegen bei meiner Rede zur ersten
Lesung des hinweisgeberschutzgesetzes
hatte ich sie liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Ampel darum gebeten die
Zeit bis zur zweiten und dritten Lesung
zu nutzen um die Anregungen aus der
Praxis also der Unternehmen die die
Regelungen umsetzen sollen und der
Hinweisgeber die durch die Regelungen
geschützt werden sollen mit in das
Gesetz einfließen zu lassen so wie sie
sich das in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag auch
vorgegeben haben lassen sie uns
überprüfen was sich im Vergleich zum
ersten Gesetzentwurf getan hat und ob
sich Verbesserungen für die Praxis
ergeben wir versetzen uns dafür in die
Lage eines potentiellen Hinweisgebers
also eines Arbeitnehmers in einer
Behörde oder einem Unternehmen der einen
Verstoß entdeckt und überlegt sich
diesen äh überlegt diesen zu melden für
den Hinweisgeber stellt sich heute noch
immer die Frage ob der Verstoß in der
melden will überhaupt in den
Anwendungsbereich des Gesetzes fällt und
er dadurch geschützt ist sie lassen den
Hinweisgeber weiterhin mit Ernährung
dieser Frage und den unbestimmten
Rechtsbegriffen alleine das ist kein
hinweisgeberschutz
hat der Hinweisgeber entschieden dass er
den Verstoß meldet hat er zu überlegen
wo er der Meldung erstattet dies kann er
entweder intern bei seinem Arbeitgeber
tun oder eben sich an eine externe
Meldestelle wenden entgegen der
sinnvollen Empfehlung der EU-Richtlinie
die interne der externen Meldung
vorzuziehen sah der bisherige
Gesetzentwurf keine Reihenfolge der
Meldungen vor diesen Punkt haben viele
Sachverständige bereits in der
Verbändeanhörung und auch in der
Sachverständigen Anhörung bemängelt im
Änderungsantrag Unternehmen Sie nun den
zaghaften versucht der internen Meldung
den Vorzug zu geben leider bleibt es bei
einem Versuch es gibt lediglich eine
halbherzige Aufforderung an die
Unternehmen Anreize für die interne
Meldung zu schaffen
auch die Regelung nach der die externe
Meldestelle den Hinweisgeber in
geeigneten Fällen auf die Möglichkeit
einer internen Meldung hinweisen soll
wirft mehr Fragen auf als sie
beantwortet ist mit dem Hinweis dass
externe Verfahren beendet was passiert
wenn der Hinweisgeber auf diesen Hinweis
hin den Verstoß zusätzlich intern meldet
wird dann doppelt bearbeitet und durch
den Umweg über die externe Meldestelle
geht weiterhin viel Zeit verloren diese
Zeit hätte das Unternehmen nutzen können
um den Missstand abzustellen denn genau
darauf kommt es doch an die Missstände
zu erkennen und schnell abzustellen ich
hoffe nicht
dass das der Unternehmensschutz ist von
dem Sie Herr Minister Buschmann in ihren
Ausführungen zur ersten Lesung
gesprochen haben
unser Hinweisgeber will nun den Verstoß
anonym melden denn er ist selbst
Beteiligter
bisher war im Gesetzentwurf nicht
verpflichtend vorgesehen dass eine
Meldung auch anonym abgegeben werden
kann das hätte den Hinweisgeber in
unserem Fall davon abgehalten zu melden
die Möglichkeit der anonymen Meldung
haben sie entgegen anfänglicher
vehementer Ablehnung in der ersten
Debatte nun in das Gesetz mit
aufgenommen und machen die Möglichkeit
zur Abgabe einer anonymenmeldung
verpflichtend außerdem können die
Meldestellen und selbst entscheiden
welchen Hinweisen sie zuerst noch gehen
die Priorisierung der Bearbeitung der
nicht anonymenmeldungen vor den anonymen
Meldungen wurde aufgehoben das ist
einmal ein großer Schritt hin zu mehr
Praxisnähe es bleibt fest zu halten das
war einige gute
praxisrelevante Änderungen aufgenommen
wurden jedoch bleibt der Gesetzentwurf
weit hinter den Erwartungen für ein
gutes und vor allem
praxistaugliches Gesetz zurück
Fortschritt meine liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Ampel sieht anders aus
herzlichen Dank
ich schließe die Aussprache wir kommen
zur Abstimmung über den von der
Bundesregierung eingebrachten
Gesetzentwurf für einen besseren Schutz
Hinweis gebender Personen sowie zur
Umsetzung der Richtlinie zum Schutz von
Personen die Verstöße gegen das
Unionsrechts melden der Rechtsausschuss
empfiehlt unter Buchstabe a seiner
Beschlussempfehlung auf Drucksache
4.909 den Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung auf Drucksachen
3442 und
3.709 in der ausschussfassung anzunehmen
hierzu liegt ein Änderungsantrag der
Fraktion der AFD auf Drucksache
4.969 vor wir stimmen zuerst über den
Änderungsantrag ab wer stimmt für diesen
Antrag das ist die afd-fraktion wer
stimmt dagegen
das sind die übrigen Fraktionen des
Hauses damit ist der änderungs-
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
Gesetzentwurf in der ausschussfassung
zustimmen wollen um das Handzeichen
das sind die
Koalitionsfraktionen wer stimmt dagegen
cdu/csu-fraktion und die afd-fraktion
Enthaltungen die Fraktion DIE LINKE der
Gesetzentwurf ist damit in zweiter
Beratung angenommen dritte Beratung und
Schlussabstimmung ich bitte diejenigen
die dem Gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen
sich zu erheben
das sind die Koalitionsfraktionen wer
stimmt dagegen
die cdu/csu-fraktion afd-fraktion
Enthaltungen die Fraktion DIE LINKE
damit ist der Gesetzentwurf in dritter
Beratung angenommen
weiterhin empfiehlt der Ausschuss unter
Buchstabe c seine Beschlussempfehlung
auf Drucksache
40009 eine Entschließung anzunehmen wer
stimmt für diese Beschlussempfehlung
das sind die Fraktionen die Linke SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und die FDP wer
stimmt dagegen
cdu/csu-fraktion die afd-fraktion
Enthaltungen sehe ich nicht die
Beschlussempfehlung ist damit angenommen
wir kommen nun zur Abstimmung über den
Entschließungsantrag der Fraktion der
cdu/csu auf Drucksache 4.914 wer stimmt
für diesen Entschließungsantrag das ist
die cdu/csu-fraktion wer stimmt dagegen
das sind die Fraktionen die Linke SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP
Enthaltungen die afd-fraktion denn
schließungsantrag ist damit abgelehnt
und damit ist auch dieser
Tagesordnungspunkt am sogenannten
angekommen es geht jetzt um den
Tagesordnungspunkt Stärkung der
Bundespolizei es liegt vor ein Antrag
der Fraktion der CDU CSU sie möchte dass
die Bundespolizei weiter gestärkt wird
bekanntermaßen braucht sie mehr Personal
bessere Bezahlung zeitgemäße
handlungsbefugnisse und Union
argumentiert hierzu insbesondere vor dem
Hintergrund des Kriegs Russlands gegen
die Ukraine dieser Krieg habe nicht nur
aus dem politische Folgen sondern erhöhe
auch die innenpolitische Bedrohung in
Deutschland gezielte Sabotage Akte
könnte es geben insbesondere gegen im
kritische Infrastrukturen es gibt eine
ansteigende Anzahl illegaler
Grenzübertritte sagt die Unionsfraktion
Bedrohung durch Extremismus und
Islamismus so wie der Kampf gegen Clan
krimination klar Kriminalität spielten
auch noch eine wichtige Rolle so wie
gesagt der Antrag der oder im Antrag der
Unionsfraktion es gibt übrigens auch ein
Gesetzentwurf zu diesem Sektor aus der
Ampelkoalition dass wir hier hin und
wieder anklingen aber zunächst Michael
Brandt für die Unionsfraktion
sie verteidigt gegen Extremismus von
rechts und links gegen Islamismus klar
Kriminalität gegen koten Hooligans oder
gewaltbereite Einzeltäter ihr Einsatz
ist zudem unverzichtbar zum Schutz
unserer Außengrenzen und im Namen der
cdu/csu und sicherlich auch im Namen des
ganzen Hauses möchte ich dafür den
Polizistinnen und Polizisten im Einsatz
den Respekt des ganzen deutschen
Bundestages aussprechen
Innenminister der Union haben die größte
Modernisierung und Stärkung der
Bundespolizei ihre Geschichte
verantwortet es wurden allein von 2017
bis 2021 über 8.000 neue Stellen
geschaffen die Besoldung und die
Polizeizulage verbessert und die
Bundespolizei auf insgesamt 54.000
Personen gestärkt heute müssen wir
feststellen die erste
spd-innenministerin dreht die Zeit
zurück die Bundespolizei wird wieder auf
Kante genäht Personal wird abgebaut
2023 hören Sie zu kommt ist zu einer
Personalkürzung um 1,5 Prozent in der
Verwaltung obwohl es seit 2016 einen
aufwuchs an Einsatzkräften von über 30
Prozent gab liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das kann in keiner Organisation
funktionieren wenn Sie Ihre Opposition
nicht glauben dann hören sie auf die
Gewerkschaft
die versprochene ruhegehaltsfähigkeit
Frau Feser Fehlanzeige bis heute nichts
passiert
it-gestützter Grenzschutz Stichwort
Smartphone die aktuellen Mittel im
Haushalt sind unzureichen um selbst die
eigenen eu-verpflichtungen einzuhalten
und obwohl wir wegen des massiven
Anstiegs von Migration dringend weiteres
Personal an unseren Grenzen benötigen
wird dies verweigert von zehn
Einsatzhundertschaften zu Unterstützung
völlig überlasteter Beamten hat Frau
Feser gerade mal vier bewilligt kein
Wunder dass angesichts dieser
Entwicklung und der Enttäuschung selbst
junge Beamte inzwischen über den
Ausstieg aus der Bundespolizei
nachdenken ich habe diese Telefonate
diese Woche geführt mit Beamten die an
der Grenze im Einsatz sind das sind
alarmierende ja besorgniserregende
Anzeichen
und besorgniserregendes auch dass nun
ausgerechnet die verantwortliche
Ministerin die Anerkennung der Realität
verweigert ja sogar davon spricht dass
es gar keine migrationskrise gäbe hier
im Deutschen Bundestag am 24 November
wenn sie von der Bundespolizei an der
Grenze Länder und bis hin zu den
Kommunen alle so massiv im Stich lassen
die hier an die an den Rand der
Belastungsgrenze kommen schaden sie
unserem Gemeinwesen
sie wollen wie wir Extremismus bekämpfen
dann bitte achten Sie darauf keine
Anlässe zu Erstarkung von Extremismus zu
liefern stärken wir gemeinsam diejenigen
die mit der doppelten Migration aus der
Ukraine und auch aus anderen Ländern vor
gewaltigen Herausforderungen stehen
lassen Sie unser Land in dieser Lage
nicht im Stich
eine moderne Bundespolizei braucht ein
modernen Rahmen für Ihre Arbeit für
diesen Rahmen legen wir als cdu/csu
heute einen umfassenden Antrag vor mit
konkreten Vorschlägen dazu zählen
erstens ausreichendes Personal zweitens
moderne Ausstattung und drittens sehr
wichtig zeitgemäße Befugnisse und
Zuständigkeiten zur effektiven
Verbrechensbekämpfung und
Strafverfolgung organisierte
Kriminalität ist ein ganz komplexes
Phänomen Rauschgift Geldwäsche
Waffenhandel Menschenhandel liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen statt kleinster
gemeinsamer Nenner in der Ampel statt
Blockaden braucht es Reformen statt
Lehrer Worte und Entwürfe einen großen
Entwurf
in der letzten Koalition hatten wir
gemeinsam erreicht dass der Bundestag
eine breite Modernisierung des
bundespolizeigesetzes von 1994 auf den
Weg brachte niemand konnte erwarten dass
die abgestimmten Kompromisse im
Bundesrat auf der Zielgerade gekippt
würden die diese Blockade bleibt eine
große fehlerleistung und auch ein
Schaden für die innere Sicherheit
unseres Landes umso wichtiger bleibt es
einen neuen Anlauf zu Unternehmen im
Ringen mit den Ländern dürfen nicht
wieder Kompetenzstreit oder Ideologien
notwendige Reformen für die
Bundespolizei und innere Sicherheit
blockieren und vor diesem Hintergrund
ist es falsch und auch politisch feige
Frau Ministerin Fezer ein ziemlich
inhaltslehr-entwurf für ein Gesetz
vorzulegen der nur minimale Anpassungen
beinhaltet und aus dem die Angst vor den
notwendigen Reformen spricht es kann ja
sein dass die hessische Wahlkämpferin
ein schnelles Gesetz will selbst ohne
Substanz aber das hilft der
Bundespolizei nicht
Kompetenzen bei Cyberangriffen kein Wort
und gefährlich auch nach dem Anschlag
auf den Berliner Weihnachtsmarkt vor
genau sechs Jahren dem brutalen Fall
Amri soll die Bundespolizei auch weiter
keine Haft zur Sicherung der Abschiebung
vornehmen können liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Ampel das darf so nicht
bleiben
nichts Zaghaftigkeit sondern Mut
brauchen die Reform gerade in so einer
unsicheren Zeit lassen Sie uns die
Bundespolizei diesen wichtigen Pfeiler
unserer Demokratie gemeinsam stärken
Michael Brandt für die Unionsfraktion
zum Antrag der Unionsfraktion zur
Stärkung der Bundespolizei und dazu
spricht jetzt Uli Grötsch aus der
SPD-Fraktion der warmer Polizeibeamter
bevor er in den Bundestag kam
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen lassen Sie mich
am Anfang dieser Debatte eine Sache
sagen die für sehr wichtig heute aus uns
alles Sicht lassen Sie uns in Zeiten wie
diesen nicht ist Sicherheitsbehörden
instrumentalisieren lassen Sie die
Sicherheitsbehörden raus aus
parteipolitischen Spielchen tragen Sie
nicht den hessischen Landtagswahlkampf
in den Deutschen Bundestag schon gar
nicht wenn es um unsere
Sicherheitsbehörden geht wir haben alle
gesehen dass das Thema dafür dass die
Zeiten dafür viel zu ernst sind denn und
das wissen sie alle auch wenn sie es
womöglich in der folgenden Debatte
negieren werden sie alle wissen dass
keine Behörde des Bundes und somit auch
keine Sicherheitsbehörde in den letzten
Jahren einen so großen aufwuchs erfahren
hat wie das bei der Bundespolizei der
Fall war und ich sage zu liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Herausforderungen werden größer ja für
ja für alle Sicherheitsbehörden und
damit natürlich auch für die
Bundespolizei und das ist mir wichtig zu
sagen
diese aufwuchs war der Beginn eines
Weges einer Entwicklung die auch in der
Zukunft ihre Fortsetzung finden wird und
auf dem als nächstes und sehr zeitnah
die Schaffung eines modernen
Rechtsrahmens für die Bundespolizei
steht ein neues bundespolizeigesetz
und
lassen Sie mich das an die Adresse der
bundesinnenministerin sagen ich bin froh
und dankbar darüber Frau Ministerin dass
Sie wissen welche zentrale Rolle die
Bundespolizei im sicherheitsgefüge der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland einnimmt und
und das ist ja sogar noch wichtiger dass
sie auch entsprechend handeln Herr
Ministerin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen dass es vor allem in Zeiten wie
diesen von elementarer Wichtigkeit und
ich sage schon auch an die Adresse des
Antragstellers sie hatten 16 Jahre lang
Zeit so lange hatten sie das
Bundesinnenministerium geführt sie
hatten mehr als genug Zeit das alles
umzusetzen was sie ihren in ihrem Antrag
noch mal aufgeschrieben haben als wohl
eine Art Revival wenn man so möchte ich
sage ihnen seien sie auch froh darüber
dass sie in den Jahren 2013 bis 2021 in
der großen Koalition die
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion an ihrer Seite
hatte wenn es um die Bundespolizei geht
ich nimm Dich beim nächsten Satz
ausdrücklich aus lieber Michael Brandt
aber man hat schon gemerkt
dass Ihr Verständnis für die
Bundespolizei ein sehr wackliches ist
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
wir werden hier in Kürze den neuen
Entwurf für das bundespolizeigesetz für
ein Update des Rechtsrahmens wenn man so
möchte denen es übrigens das wissen
einige seit sage und schreibe 1994
unverändert zu gibt beraten und sie alle
sind gerne aufgefordert im Gesetz dann
zuzustimmen und sich somit mit uns mit
der Ampelkoalition auf den Weg zu machen
und ich sage Ihnen auch mehr als 50.000
Beschäftigte bei der Bundespolizei
würden es wohl gut finden
Gesetz nicht gestritten und polemisiert
wird so wie sie es eben versucht haben
und so glaube ich in der Debatte auch
noch weiter tun werden sondern wenn sie
sich ich sage es nochmal gerade in
Zeiten wie diesen alle hinter ihren
Sicherheitsbehörden versammeln und für
Sie arbeiten denn ohne sicher ohne
Bundespolizei ist Sicherheit in
Deutschland nicht denkbar dafür können
wir alle jeden Beschäftigten
dort dankbar sein und ganz aktuell wir
wissen das für die Arbeit bei der
Enttarnung des Rechts Reichsbürger
terror-netzwerkes 450
bundespolizistinnen und Polizisten haben
letzte Woche zum gelingendes Anti
terroreinsatzes beigetragen das war
team-work der Sicherheitsbehörden vom
allerfeinsten und das wird auch noch ein
eine Weile weitergehen dieses Teamwork
in der Auswertung der Daten wir haben
das am Montag in der Sondersitzung des
Innenausschusses gehört hat ja erst
begonnen und ich bin gespannt
was da noch alles zum Vorschein kommt
und wer noch alles zum Vorschein kommt
im Zuge der weiteren Ermittlungen und
auch welchen Gruppierungen und am Ende
Parteien diese Leute angehören werden
wir
haben auch im Haushalt 2023 die
Bundespolizei weiter gestärkt zu
bekommen die Bundespolizei zum Beispiel
1000 neue Stellen um die Anwärterinnen
und Anwärter auch übernehmen zu können
das Bundeskriminalamt wächst weiter auf
um 180 Stellen zur Bekämpfung von
organisierter Kriminalität und
Extremismus und das alles trotz
auslaufender Corona konjunkturmittel und
ich glaube wir sind uns alle einig das
ist die richtige
Prioritätensetzung für die Zukunft
dazu gehört aber auch liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen dass wir alles dafür tun
die schwarzen Schafe unter denen also
diejenigen die nicht auf dem Boden des
Grundgesetzes stehen die das Negative
Potenzial haben den Ruf der ganzen
Behörde zu gefährden dass wir alles
dafür tun Verfassungsfeinde aus dem
Staatsdienst zu entfernen und zwar
schnell und konsequent
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen lassen
Sie mich am Ende sagen unsere Polizei
ein genießen in Deutschland zu Recht
sehr hohes Ansehen das hat eine aktuelle
Erhebung des Bundeskriminalamtes wieder
ergeben in der über 80 Prozent der
Befragten sagen dass sie den Polizeien
in Deutschland Vertrauen auch das zeigt
uns wir sind auf einem guten Weg und
deshalb auch wenn Ihr Antrag so glaube
ich so nehme ich ihn war er wohl als
schaufensterantrag kurz vor Weihnachten
gedacht ist wir brauchen ihn nicht das
wissen Sie wir lehnen in auch deshalb ab
vielen Dank
aus der SPD-Fraktion in der Debatte zum
Antrag der Unionsfraktion zur Stärkung
der Bundespolizei der nächste Redner ist
Steffen ja nicht aus der AFD Fraktion
auch er war polizeibeamt haben bevor er
in den Bundestag kam
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
die Bundespolizei nicht politisch zu
instrumentalisieren wir nehmen Sie und
die Regierung immer wieder gerne
die Beschäftigung mit der inneren
Sicherheit darf für die Politik niemals
zum Selbstzweck werden vor fast sechs
Jahren am 19 dezember 2016
tötet der Polizei und
nachrichtendienstlich bekannte die
islamistische Attentäter Anis Amri auf
dem Berliner Breitscheidplatz insgesamt
13 Menschen und verletzt ist 67 Personen
solche Kräutern dürfen sich nie wieder
wiederholen in drei Tagen werden wir
wieder in angemessener Form der Opfer
dieser schrecklichen Tat gedenken ich
bin in Gedanken bei den verwandten der
Opfer
ein unverzichtbarer Bestandteil zum
Schutz der öffentlichen Sicherheit aber
tatsächlich auch zum Schutz der
nationalen Grenzen der Schienenwege
unter Flughäfen ist unsere Bundespolizei
circa 54.000 Mitarbeiter sind in diesem
Bereich tätig von 2017 bis 2021 haben
sich die Planstellen bei der
Bundespolizei von 42.000 auf ca 50.000
Stellen erhöht der jährliche Haushalt in
selben Zeitraum von 3,3 Milliarden Euro
auf 4,7 Milliarden ist angehoben worden
jeder einzelne Cent den wir für unsere
Bundespolizei investiert haben ist gut
angelegtes Geld für die Zukunft
Deutschlands die Bundespolizei muss auch
zukünftig weiter gestärkt und ausgebaut
werden
aber es bleibt nach wie vor viel zu tun
als Abgeordneter habe ich mich in den
sitzungsfreien Wochen mehrfach zu den
Polizeidienststellen
Polizeidienststellen aufgesucht und mich
mit dienststellenleitern und Beamten des
Polizeivollzugsdienstes unterhalten
hierbei sprechen
so fleißig sind wir hierbei könnte ich
mir ein eigenes Bild zu den
Gegebenheiten und in Anforderungen in
täglichen Abläufen bei der Bundespolizei
machen einzelne Schwerpunkte sind dabei
immer wieder zur Sprache gekommen zur
Bekämpfung der schleuserkriminalität und
zur Ahndung der einreisestraftaten
sollten die Beamten zukünftig möglich
sein auch außerhalb der 30 km-zone im
gesamten Bundesgebiet eigenständig
ermitteln zu dürfen auch die ent
körperarbeiten bei der von der
Bundespolizei zuerst festgestellten
Straftaten ist ein wichtiger Beitrag um
behördliche Ressourcen zu bündeln die
derzeit noch gängige Praxis eine
Strafakte quasi für die
Staatsanwaltschaft komplett
vorzubereiten um sie dann die
Landespolizei zu übergeben widerspricht
modernen
effektivitätsgrundsätzen hier müssen
dringend rechtliche Rahmenbedingungen
geändert werden
die Privatisierung der Autobahn hat
insbesondere in Grenzregionen dazu
geführt dass die Einrichtung von
größeren Kontrollstellen nicht mehr
unangekündigt möglich ist sondern zuvor
bei der privaten Betreibergesellschaft
angemeldet werden muss die
darauffolgenden dauern zeigen auf den
Navigationsgeräten der Fahrzeuge leiten
den zu kontrollierenden Verkehr dann
regelmäßig in andere an der
Kontrollstelle vorbei ein
Überraschungseffekt wird hier durch
deutlich eingeschränkt es bräuchte auch
vermehrt sogenannte verkehrstrichter um
die Geschwindigkeit des fahrverkehrs auf
der derartigen Kontrollen des Verkehrs
auf das Autobahn zu verlangsamen eine
solche Mittelbeschaffung wäre ein
wichtiger Beitrag zum Arbeitsschutz
unserer eingesetzten Beamten
bei länger eingerichteten
Kontrollstellen beispielsweise auf
Autobahnen benötigen die Beamten
insbesondere an kalten Wintertagen aber
auch zum Schutz vor Regen und Nässe
mobile Kontrollstellen Ausstattungen
praxisbezogene Bedarfe sind da
beispielsweise sogenannte agrarzelte
welche die als Überdachung als für
Kontrollen von Reisebussen erforderlich
sind damit die Fahrgäste und Beamten bei
Wind und Wetter nicht im Freien stehen
summa summarum benötigt die
Bundespolizei zukünftig vermehrt Lager
angepasste Einsatzmittel um
Arbeitsweisen optimieren zu können
eines der größten Probleme in
Dienstalltag der Bundespolizei bleibt
aber die viel zu geringe Zahl an
Rückführung von Personen die sich
unerlaubt in Deutschland aufhalten im
Jahr 2021 waren
33.6.600 Rückführung von Ausländern
vorgesehen allerdings wurden davon nur
die Hälfte also rund 15.000
Rückführungen auch wirklich vollzogen
und der Jahresbericht der Bundespolizei
sagt aus für die Diskrepanz an
Rückführung war hauptursächlich dass die
zur Abschiebung vorgesehenen Personen
der Bundespolizei am Flugtag nicht
Zurückführung übergeben werden konnten
hier müssten sie Frau Innenministerin
ansetzen und endlich eine wirksame
abschiebe Offensive einleiten anstatt
die ihre Energie bei der Jagd auf
phantombedrohung zu verschwenden
während die im Jahr 2021 im
Zuständigkeitsbereich der
Bundesregierung festgestellten
Straftaten in vielen Bereichen
rückläufig waren lagen die größten
Zunahmen in den Bereichen Betrug und bei
den Verstößen gegen das
Aufenthaltsgesetz ich sage sage uns
schreibe
171.000 Verstöße gegen das
Aufenthaltsgesetz hat allein die
Bundesregierung im Jahr 2021
festgestellt dies ist nicht zuletzt auf
die Politik der offenen Grenzen unsere
Bundesregierung zurückzuführen
leider schweigt sich der Antrag der CDU
dazu aus wie sie die genaue
Zuständigkeitsverteilung bei der
Strafverfolgung durch Land und Bund
voneinander abgrenzen wollen eine
Doppelzuständigkeit von Bundes- und
Landespolizei zur Durchführung eines
strafprozessualen Ermittlungsverfahren
etwa bei Tagen die ein Bahnhöfen
begangen werden würden zu einem
unüberschaubaren behördenchaos führen
das Thema Strafverfolgung ist aber zu
bedeutend als dass man es hier
schaufensterartig in nur drei Zeilen
abschließend darstellen könnte zum
Schluss sei noch gesagt Beamte und
insbesondere Polizeibeamte die mit die
Recht und Gesetz verpflichtet sind und
nicht den politischen politischen
Fantasien der jeweiligen Regierung
unterliegen dürfen nicht nur die
Bundespolizisten gehören vor den
Generalverdacht geschützt sondern auch
neue Bewerber für den
Polizeivollzugsdienst einen weiteren
politischen gesinnungstift von Nancy
faces Gnaden wir entschieden ab
ich wünsche allen deutschen einen
friedlichen vierten Advent und frohe
Weihnachten
[Applaus]
nächste Redner für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen Marcel Emmerich
Marcel Emmerich ist Obmann im
Innenausschuss des Bundestags
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren
zum Antrag der Union will ich zunächst
sagen das Ansehen die Bundespolizei zu
stärken und zu unterstützen das teilen
wir natürlich die Angehörigen der
Sicherheitsbehörden insgesamt und der
Bundespolizei im speziellen die rund um
die Uhr für Sicherheit sorgen und uns
bei der Verteidigung der freiheitlich
demokratischen Grundordnung unterstützen
verdienen Respekt und Anerkennung und
das war für die Bundespolizei mit Blick
auf das 50-jährige Jubiläum der GSG 9 an
dieser Stelle nochmal herzlichen
Glückwunsch dem Einsatz beim G7 Gipfel
in Ellmau der bundesweiten Razzia gegen
die Reichsbürger letzte Woche und der
normalen Arbeits in dem normalen
Arbeitsalltag ein mehr als
ereignisreiches Jahr vielen Dank an die
Polizistinnen und Polizisten für die
professionelle Arbeit und das hohe
Engagement
zu den wichtigsten Aufgaben einer guten
Innenpolitik gehört das die Sicherheit
der Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu
gewährleisten um Gefahren abzuwehren und
Straftaten verfolgen zu können muss die
Polizei folgerichtig handlungsfähig
aufgestellt sein es braucht dafür vor
allem gute technische Ausstattung und
genug Personal und dafür sorgen wir auch
als Ampelkoalition konkret zum Beispiel
personell mit einem kontinuierlichen
Stellen zu stellen Zuwachs für die
nächsten Jahre technisch nehmen wir Geld
in die Hand für Boote und neue Drohnen
damit stärken wir ganz konkret die
Arbeit für die Bundespolizei
wenn man sich ihren Antrag dann weiter
anschaut Liebe Union dann stellt man
fest dass es vor allem ein Katalog
voller Gesetzesverschärfung ist nichts
haben sie ausgelassen quellentikerü
online Durchsuchungen Gesichtserkennung
Wohnraumüberwachung ohne jede Balance
wie ohne jede Balance da bleibt wirklich
kein Schäfchen im trocknen
und das ist problematisch denn wenn wir
über die Polizei reden dann reden wir
vor allem immer auch über das Verhältnis
zwischen zwischen Staat und Gesellschaft
zwischen Bürgerinnen und Bürgern und dem
Staat und dabei gilt es nun mal die
Grundrechte gegen unverhältnismäßige
Eingriffe des Staates zu schützen wir
leben in einem der sichersten Länder
dieser Welt in dem es zum gleich die
Freiheit des Einzelnen so gering gilt
wie möglich einzuschränken diese Balance
aufrecht zu halten ist unser Ziel und es
geht immer noch der Grundsatz immer
schärfere Gesetze für nicht automatisch
zu mehr Sicherheit und deswegen ist es
elementar jede Maßnahme auch
Verhältnismäßigkeit auch Wirksamkeit und
rechtfertigkeit zu prüfen und genau das
tun wir
und sie tun das nicht sie tun das nicht
mit ihrer Forderung nach quentica und
online Durchsuchungen
ignorieren sie die hohen Anforderungen
die das Bundesverfassungsgericht daran
in der Vergangenheit zu Recht gestellt
hat immer mehr vom immergleichen hat in
den letzten Jahren vor allem das
Bundesverfassungsgericht auf
trabgehalten mit solchen Rechts unsere
Vorschlägen die am Ende wieder in
karlsrelanden verlieren alle die
Freiheit die Bürgerinnen und Bürger und
am Ende auch die Sicherheit
sie fordern vor allem Dinge die
rechtsunsicher sind und ob sie
Sicherheit beitragen ist fraglich und
Lebens stattdessen Dinge ab die das
Vertrauen in die Polizei Stärken zum
Beispiel die polizeibeauftragten oder
die Pseudonyme Kennzeichnungspflicht und
da will ich Ihnen noch mal was sagen zum
Thema Verhältnis zwischen Staat und
Gesellschaft denn darum geht es auch bei
der PSE bei der Pseudonym
Kennzeichnungspflicht es ist so die
Polizei übt das Gewaltmonopol des
Staates aus und kann mit ihren Maßnahmen
in die Grundrechte aller Menschen
eingreifen es ist deshalb unerlässlich
in jedem Fall ein transparentes und
rechtsstaatliches Handeln
sicherzustellen und das das trägt die
dazu trägt die Einführung einer
Kennzeichnungspflicht bei das hat auch
das Bundesverwaltungsgericht schon 2019
bestätigt die Pseudonyme
Kennzeichnungspflicht dient demnach zum
einen der Stärkung der Transparenz und
der Bürger Nähe der Polizei zum anderen
gewährleistet sie die leichtere die
Arbeit bei Fehlerverhalten damit
beruhigt sich die berüchtigt damit
berücksichtigt Sie außerdem die
Rechtsprechung des Europäischen
Gerichtshofs für Menschenrechte mit
ihrer Ablehnung dazu sind sie nicht mehr
auf der Höhe der Zeit sie ist
mittlerweile Standard in der Mehrheit
der Bundesländer außer in Bayern und dem
Saarland ist sie überall beschlossen
oder auf den Weg gebracht in vielen
unionsrücken mit regierten Ländern
deswegen ist das im Endeffekt auch im
Sinne einer konsistenten bundesweiten
polizeipolitik sie sehen
sie sehen wir verfolgen einen klaren
Kompass wir haben die Sicherheit der
Menschen und den demokratischen
Rechtsstaat fest im Blick und wir
schaffen einen Rechtsrahmen wir schaffen
Rahmenbedingungen für eine
handlungsfähige und transparente Polizei
das bringen wir auch mit dem
bundespolizeigesetz auf den Weg das
werden sie noch sehen vielen Dank für
Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Marcel Emmerich für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen da ist ja ob man im
Innenausschuss und der nächste Redner
wird sein andre Hahn aus der
Linksfraktion ob man eben
parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
es war ja irgendwie schon zu erwarten
dass CDU und CSU passend zur
Weihnachtszeit noch ein paar Wünsche für
den law and order Geschenkekorb
präsentieren würden mit dem vorliegenden
Antrag hat die Union auch tatsächlich
geliefert
Aktie am meisten der darin enthaltenen
Forderungen aus Sicht der Linken
allerdings nicht fangen wir mal mit dem
unabhängigen polizeibeauftragten an den
sie immer wieder leidenschaftlich
ablehnen wovor haben Sie eigentlich
Angst liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von
der Union eigentlich müssten doch alle
Demokraten einen Interesse daran haben
dass die übergroße Mehrheit der
Polizisten die verantwortungsbewusst
ihren Dienst versehen dadurch geschützt
werden das schwarze Schafe mit
übergriffigem oder rechtswidrigen
Verhalten möglichst schnell aus dem
Dienst entfernt werden können
in dieser Woche in dieser Woche
antwortete das Innenministerium auf
unsere Anfrage zu den Zahlen über
Beschwerden die entlang von racial
Profiling Vorwürfen eingegangen sind vom
Januar 2021 bis Ende November 2022
wurden danach 100 Beschwerden
eingereicht darunter ist allerdings
nicht eine einzige Beschwerde die nach
Prüfung als begründet eingestuft wurden
wäre acht Fälle seien nicht aufklärbar
drei noch im Bearbeitung nun will ich
den Einsatzkräften und der Bundespolizei
keine Falschmeldung oder
beschwerdeunterdrückung unterstellen
aber schon rein statistisch gesehen ist
es höchst unwahrscheinlich dass nicht
eine einzige begründete Beschwerde in
einem Zeitraum von zwei Jahren dabei
gewesen sein soll mir sagt das wir
brauchen mehr denn je ein unabhängigen
polizeibeauftragten
Kollege Thron von der Union beklagt in
der aktuellen Ausgabe des lobby-magazins
moderne Polizei das angeblich zu große
Misstrauen gegenüber Polizisten wir
müssen uns gerade jetzt in der
Weihnachtszeit auch gar nicht streiten
wie die vorliegenden Zahlen auszulegen
sind wer Recht hat mit seiner
Wahrnehmung und wer falsch liegt zwei
Dinge allerdings geben mir schon zu
denken erstens zahlreiche
zivilgesellschaftliche Initiativen
nehmen ein Problem war dass ich dann
aber nicht mal ansatzweise in den
Aufklärungsraten widerspiegelt und dass
ich nur wenige von
rachialing betroffene Menschen überhaupt
dadurch durchringen eine offizielle
Beschwerde einzureichen ist angesichts
dieser Zahlen nicht verwunderlich
ich könnte Ihnen jetzt hier einige
persönliche Erfahrungen berichten die
ich in den letzten Jahren im Zug von der
tschechischen Grenze bei Bad Schandau
auf dem Weg nach Berlin erlebt habe aber
dafür fehlt mir leider die Zeit die
Fakten machen aber deutlich lieber
Kollege throm dass sie doch eigentlich
genau jetzt einen unabhängigen
polizeibeauftragten begrüßen müssen und
wenn sie dann recht behalten würden und
nahezu alle Beschwerden sich als
unbegründet erweisen würden dann
schaffen wir den beauftragten eben
wieder ab aber für Ihre komplette
Verweigerungshaltung habe ich keinerlei
Verständnis
meine Damen und Herren auch sonst ist
der Antrag voll von Geschenken an die
Bundespolizei die die Union verteilen
will Gummigeschosse und Tesa sollen
eingeführt werden ohne dass überhaupt
belegbar ist dass dadurch der Einsatz
von Schusswaffen wirklich vermieden
werden kann und natürlich ist die Union
auch weiterhin gegen eine anonymisierte
Kennzeichnungspflicht für Polizistinnen
und Polizisten haben Sie sich eigentlich
mal im Rest von Europa oder in den USA
umgeschaut da ist diese Kennzeichnung
längst etabliert und das ist auch gut so
geben sie endlich ihren Widerstand
dagegen auf
meine Damen und Herren als vom Bundestag
gewähltes Mitglied des Gremiums dass die
Eingriffe in die Unverletzlichkeit der
Wohnung nach Artikel 13 Grundgesetz
überprüfen sollen muss ich eine
entsprechenden Befugnis für die
Bundespolizei eine klare Absage erteilen
für die Abwehr einer dringenden Gefahr
für Leib und Leben ist der Lauschangriff
auf den privaten Wohnraum ebenso
ungeeignet wie der Einsatz von
staatstrojanern den die Union jetzt für
die Bundespolizei fordert wir als LINKE
Leben das ab und abschließend sage ich
in Richtung Koalition legen sie endlich
einen eigenen Gesetzentwurf für ein
neues bundespolizeigesetz vor dann
könnten sie sich erstmals innenpolitisch
als sogenannte fortschrittskoalition
beweisen vielen Dank und frohe
Weihnachten
andre Hahn für die Linksfraktion in der
Debatte zur Stärkung der Bundespolizei
der einen Antrag der Unionsfraktion
zugrunde liegt manuell Höferlin aus der
FDP-Fraktion ist ja nächste Redner er
ist in politischer Sprecher
sehr verehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren
vor kurzem war ich zu Hause in Mainz
wieder mal bei der Bundespolizei im
Hauptbahnhof und dort müssen rund 70
bundespolizistinnen und Bundespolizisten
ihren Dienst tun es gibt wenig Platz für
die wichtige Arbeit zu wenig Platz für
Akten für Geräte die Umkleiden dort sind
inzwischen ausgelagerten ganzes Stück
vom Gebäude hinweg und auf einen Neubau
auf einen neue größere Unterkunft warten
die Kolleginnen und Kollegen dort schon
seit Jahren der Hauptbahnhof in Mainz
ist nur eines von Beispielen die viele
Polizei Dienststellen gerade an den
Böden sind ganz ähnlich aufgestellt
dabei verdanken wir die Sicherheit an
den Bahnhöfen an den Flughäfen genau
diesen Beamten die trotz dieser Umstände
ein hohes Maß an Motivation und
Leistungsbereitschaft zeigen und das
jeden Tag und dafür möchte ich einmal
herzlichen Dank sagen
eine moderne gut ausgestattete Polizei
ist deshalb für mich eines der
wichtigsten Themen und ein zentrales
Vorhaben dieser Koalition in der
Innenpolitik und daran arbeiten wir
intensiv um die Arbeit unserer
Bundespolizisten und Bundespolizisten
besser effizienter zu gestalten denn vor
allen Dingen damit machen wir
Deutschland sicherer meine Damen und
Herren der Antrag der Union zeigt jedoch
dass sie diese Aufgabe nicht gewachsen
sind und auch in den letzten 16 Jahren
nicht gewachsen waren denn ihr Antrag
ist nichts anderes als eine Liste dessen
was sie 16 Jahre in der Innenpolitik
selbst nicht geschafft haben es ist eine
Dokumentation ihrer Versäumnisse und das
bundesp freigesetzt ist ein gutes
Beispiel denn nicht einmal das haben sie
durchgekriegt in der letzten Legislatur
und deshalb ist es gut dass ich die
fortschrittskoalition jetzt um die
Bundespolizei kümmert meine Damen und
Herren
es geht ihnen in Wirklichkeit auch gar
nicht um die Beamten das zeigt ihr
Antrag auch deutlich sondern es geht
ihnen einmal mehr um mehr Überwachung
der Telekommunikation um die Online
Durchsuchung die Wohnraumüberwachung die
automatische Gesichtserkennung und so
weiter ihre fragwürdigen Projekte mit
denen sie die Bürger immer wieder
drangsalieren wollen die sind krachend
gescheitert vor dem verfassungsgerichten
weil sie einfach nicht verfassungsfest
waren zuletzt mit der
Vorratsdatenspeicherung und sie
begreifen eines nicht mehr Überwachung
bedeutet nicht automatisch mehr
Sicherheit meine Damen und Herren
unsere Polizistinnen und Polizisten
brauchen andere Dinge viel dringender
sie brauchen bessere Ausrüstung auch
bessere Unterkünfte die Sie auf diese
seit Jahren warten sie brauchen klare
Zuständigkeitsregelungen und sie
brauchen eine verlässliche Politik und
im Gegensatz zu ihnen werden wir das
liefern sie machen ja auch ein paar ganz
gute Vorschläge in ihrem Antrag
zum Beispiel den Einsatz von Distanz
elektroimpulsgeräten sogenannten Tasern
oder bodycams leider viel zu spät weil
teilweise diese Projekte als
Pilotprojekte laufen immer noch nicht
ausgerollt sind dagegen wollen Sie jetzt
noch mehr sie wollen Gummi Geschosse bei
der Bundespolizei wollen sie ausrichten
da haben sie noch nicht mal geschafft in
den vielen Jahren die Taser ordentlich
auszurollen sie wollen sozusagen wieder
mit der Kanone auf schwarzen schießen
sie fordern jetzt eine
Sicherheitsüberprüfung bei
Neueinstellungen ein guter Vorschlag den
die FDP-Fraktion in der letzten
Wahlperiode bereits gefordert hat und
sie haben es versäumt das einzuführen
und wir gehen das jetzt mit dem neuen
Bundespolizei Gesetz an
die Arbeit der Polizei wird auch
verbessert im täglichen indem wir das
erfolgreiche Pilotprojekt P20
weiterentwickeln die Polizei zeigen in
Deutschland die Länderpolizeien die
Bundespolizei des BKA das Zeug
Kriminalamt und die Polizei des
Bundestages werden damit überall
jederzeit Zugriff auf die wichtigen
Informationen haben die sie täglich in
ihrem polizeigeschäft brauchen das
verbessert die Einsatzmöglichkeiten die
Effizienz der Polizei besser und das
verbessert die Arbeitsumstände der
Beamtinnen vor Ort meine Damen und
Herren wir sorgen für mehr
Digitalisierung die auch einen echten
Nutzen hat wir setzen uns für eine
flächendeckende Ausstattung für mobile
Endgeräte ein benutzerfreundlich direkt
Zugriff auf die relevanten Daten damit
stärken wir die Bundespolizei und sorgen
auch für moderne Sicherheitsbehörden
meine Damen und Herren
und weil ihr Antrag vor allen Dingen
eines aufzeigt nämlich was sie in den
letzten Jahren versäumt haben umzusetzen
was sie nicht geschafft haben
durchzusetzen ist es auch gut dass die
schwarzen Jahre im Innenministerium
vorbei sind die Sicherheitspolitik ist
jetzt
evidenzbasiert Grundrechts schonend und
wir schaffen verlässliche Instrumente
für die tägliche Arbeit der Polizisten
vor Ort das dürfen finde ich auch
diejenigen erwarten die im wahrsten
Sinne des Wortes jeden Tag ihren Kopf
für uns hinhalten und das werden wir
leisten vielen Dank
Manuel Höferlin war dass er in
politische Sprecher der FDP-Fraktion ihm
wird jetzt Folgen aus der Unionsfraktion
die ja diesen Antrag über den hier
diskutiert wird vorgelegt hat Petra
Nicolaisen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich würde die
Gelegenheit gerne dazu nutzen um darüber
zu sprechen wie die alltägliche Arbeit
der 54.000 bundespolizistinnen und
Bundespolizisten in unserem Land
eigentlich aussieht die Bundespolizei
führt jährlich unzählige von
Amtshandlungen aus das wissen sie
Objektschutz Grenzkontrollen Verhandlung
Festnahmen und der Kampf auch gegen die
organisierte Kriminalität gehören zu
einigen der vielfältigen Aufgaben die
Tag für Tag gewissenhaft erfüllt werden
und das sind Aufgaben die unsere
Sicherheit unserer Sicherheit dienen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen unsere
Aufgabe ist es die Bundespolizei zu
stärken dazu müssen die
Herausforderungen endlich angegangen
werden und dabei bin ich sicher der
Bundesregierung sind diese
Herausforderung und Belastung
hinlänglich bekannt und doch passiert zu
wenig
die Zahl der Aufgaben wächst der
aufgabendruck ist enorm und die
Gefahrenlage hoch wir beobachten eine
neue Qualität der Aggression gegen die
Polizei geringere Hemmschwellen die
Festnahme bewaffneter Reichsbürger und
die Polizisten Morde zum Beispiel in
Kusel wir erleben hoch
professionalisierte Strukturen im
Bereich der schleusungskriminalität und
neue Möglichkeiten neue mögliche
Gefahren durch Cyberangriffe Sabotage
und Drohnen darauf muss die
Bundespolizei vorbereitet werden weil
wir alle eine zuverlässige
funktionsfähige und gut ausgestattete
Bundespolizei erwarten und auch brauchen
mir ist es wichtig Revue passieren zu
lassen was bisher alleine in diesem Jahr
an Aufgaben hinzukamen zu Beginn dieses
Jahres waren es die
Montagsdemonstrationen und rohaufläufe
corona-demos und die vielen
Schutzsuchenden aus der Ukraine im
Sommer dann flughafenchaos wer musste
helfen die Bundespolizei Einsatz lagen
bei Fußballspielen und der Reiseverkehr
der Fans die Bundespolizei ist auch hier
gefordert und so kamen 2021 22 mehr als
400.000 Einsatzstunden zusammen in
diesem Herbst klimaaktivisten am
Berliner Flughafen Einsätze für die
Bundespolizei und nun weiter zunehmenden
Migrationsbewegungen die Bundespolizei
sichert die Grenzen und genau deshalb
haben wir diesen Antrag gestellt und
eingebracht weil wir als
cdu/csu-fraktion den Ernst der Lage
erkennen und konkrete Vorschläge machen
wir fordern sie auf Liebe
Bundesregierung in unserem Antrag hier
und heute erstens sorgen sie für mehr
Personal bei angemessener Bezahlung
zweitens starten Sie die Einsatzkräfte
sicherer und moderner aus um neuen
Herausforderungen anzugehen und das
Personal gut zu schützen und dazu gehört
auch dass sie die Situation der
Dienststellen und der Unterbringung der
Bundespolizei Regeln und drittens
greifen Sie unsere Vorschläge zu
zeitgemäßen handlungsbefugnissen bitte
auf
die Bundespolizei braucht Möglichkeiten
um neue Gefahren zu begegnen und besser
ermitteln zu können und Kollege Emmerich
der
polizeibeauftragte trägt in der Tat
nicht zu mehr Bürgernähe bei
abschließend möchte ich auch die
künftige finanzielle Situation zu
sprechen kommen und ich kann es wirklich
beim besten Willen nicht nachvollziehen
warum die Bundesregierung ausgerechnet
jetzt bei der Bundespolizei sparen will
Ihnen
[Applaus]
vernünftig ist und natürlich auch
realitätsfern
wir als unionsgeführte Bundesregierung
haben seit 2016 in diese Behörde mehr
investiert als in allen anderen
Bereichen der inneren Sicherheit und
lieber Kollege Uli Grötsch sie wissen es
besser als das was sie eben kundgetan
haben wir haben dort in großer Koalition
viel investiert und das Polizeigesetz
ist im Bundesrat gescheitert an einem
Ministerpräsidenten der SPD
was wir Mülltonne aufgebaut haben eine
höhere Personaldecke die Erhöhung der
Polizei Zulage und viele weitere
Verbesserungen das alles bauen Sie jetzt
hier sukzessive wieder ab und machen
diesen Erfolg der letzten sechs Jahre
zunichte das ist eher Wagnis als
Fortschritt was hier gerade passiert sie
sparen an Befugnissen und an Kosten und
das Zulassen unserer Sicherheit und der
Sicherheit der Einsatzkräfte das ist
absoluter Rückschritt ich muss doch
schwer hoffen dass sie sich zeitnah
besinnen herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
nächste Rednerin für die SPD-Fraktion
kamen Wege
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
demokratischen Fraktionen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren die Bundespolizei ist
aktuell sehr stark und vielfältig
gefordert in diesem Jahr sind es vor
allem die Auswirkungen des russischen
Angriffskrieges sei es der
schutzkritischer Infrastruktur auch zu
sehen oder die Unterstützung bei der
Ankunft von geflüchteten aus der Ukraine
hier möchte ich besonders erwähnen dass
die Bundespolizei dankenswerterweise
schnell reagiert hat als nach den ersten
Ankünften von ukrainischen Frauen und
Kindern Berichte über Menschenhandel und
sexualisierte Übergriffe die Runde
machten die Präsenz wurde verstärkt und
vor Ort wurde sensibilisiert genauso
muss es laufen
aber auch die Razzia gegen
reichsbürgerinnen in den vergangenen
Woche kann man nicht unerwähnt lassen
die Bundespolizei unterstützt immer
häufiger bei der Abwehr der großen
Bedrohung durch Rechtsextremismus auch
bei dieser bundesweiten Razzia war sie
mit hunderten Beamtinnen beteiligt
darunter auch viele Spezialkräfte wir
haben den Rechtsextremismus als die
aktuell größte Gefahr für die für unsere
Demokratie identifiziert und für den
Kampf gegen Rechts brauchen wir starke
Sicherheitsbehörden auf die
Bundespolizei können und müssen wir uns
an dieser Stelle verlassen zur Erfüllung
ihrer wichtigsten auf ihres wichtigsten
Auftrags benötigt die Bundespolizei
nicht wie Sie Ihren Antrag schreiben
drei sondern aus meiner Sicht sogar fünf
Dinge eine starke Bundespolizei braucht
ausreichend Personal gutes Material gute
Arbeitsbedingungen Anerkennung für die
Arbeit der Beamtinnen und schließlich
eine moderne gesetzliche
Arbeitsgrundlage all das schaffen wir
all das schafft unsere Innenministerin
Nancy fazer all das schafft die
und ich möchte Ihnen auch konkret
erläutern wie wir in diesen fünf
Bereichen aktiv werden oder bereits
jetzt aktiv geworden sind erstens mehr
Personal wir haben durch die
Haushaltsberatung 1000 neue Stellen bei
der Bundespolizei ermöglicht diese neuen
Beamtinnen werden unter anderem zum
Schutz von Flug und Sehhilfen und dem
Grenzschutz eingesetzt zweitens neues
Material wie investieren ganz gezielt in
die Bedarfe der Bundespolizei wir
schaffen das an was durch die
verstärkten Herausforderungen gebraucht
wird die Bundespolizei sehe hat
beispielsweise ein Verfahrens
Trainingszentrum mit dem modernsten
schiffführungssimulator Europas eröffnet
ein absolutes Alleinstellungsmerkmal mit
Blick auf die aktuellen
Herausforderungen im maritimen Raum ist
dies eine dringende notwendige
Weiterentwicklung ein weiteres Beispiel
im Haushalt für 2023 haben wir 21
Millionen Euro zu Beschaffung neuer
kontroll- und Streifenboote bei der
Bundespolizei See sowie mehrzweckbote
für die GSG9 vereinbart gute
Arbeitsbedingungen für Michael halt in
Deutschland kommt es auf eine motivierte
und gut ausgebildete
Bundespolizei an genau deshalb stärken
wir Supervision sowie Fort- und
Weiterbildung nur so kann man eine
attraktive Arbeitgeberin auch bleiben
Wertschätzung für Polizistinnen in
dieser Legislaturperiode werden wir
endlich die Polizei Zulage wieder in
Ruhe gehaltsfähig gestalten können das
ist uns als SPD seit vielen Jahren ein
großes Anliegen und Liebe Union bei
ihnen habe ich das jetzt noch nicht so
häufig gehört mit der Wiedereinführung
werden die Leistungen der Beamten
endlich auch finanziell anerkannt eine
gute Nachricht für die Kolleginnen und
das bundespolizeigesetz ja da stand in
großen Teilen noch aus dem Jahr 1994 und
deswegen werden wir selbstverständlich
einen Gesetzesentwurf vorlegen der
Versuch einer Modernisierung der
Grundlagen ist ja wie bereits bekannt im
Bundesrat gescheitert wir schaffen nun
ein neues und zeitgemäßes Gesetz das für
eine moderne und bürgernahe Polizei
stehen wird für diesen für dieses Ziel
ja bürgernah das ist für sie vielleicht
komisch Herr Abenteuer für uns ist das
selbstverständlich
für dieses Ziel braucht es in unseren
Augen sie sind die Grundvoraussetzung
für ein verfassungsfestes Gesetz wir
wegen genau ab welche heraus welche
handlungsbefugnisse für die
Bundespolizei notwendig sind und welche
eben nicht unser Credo ist dabei nicht
wie in ihrem Antrag mehr ist immer
besser diese Haltung würde ich als einen
konservativen Reflex bezeichnen den wir
als SPD endlich nicht mehr mittragen
müssen
stattdessen wollen wir die Bundespolizei
als Bürger nahe Polizei Stärken dafür
ist das Vertrauen in unsere
Sicherheitsbehörden ein zentraler
Schlüssel gedachte deswegen werden wir
die Kennzeichnungspflicht und einen
unabhängigen polizeibeauftragten
einführen beide Maßnahmen sind Ausdruck
einer modernen professionell und vor
allem recht staatlich arbeiten und
Polizei sie sind Ausdruck eines offenen
und transparenten Auftreten des Staates
gegenüber ihren BürgerInnen das
Vertrauen der Bürger in die Polizei wird
damit gestärkt mit Blick in die Zukunft
ist die Bundespolizei also gut
aufgestellt und besonders gut ist dass
wir jetzt die Innenministerin Stellen
vielen Dank
Carmen Wege aus der SPD-Fraktion in der
Debatte über die Bundespolizei bzw deren
Stärkung bzw den Vorstellungen die die
Unionsfraktion dazu hat die hat den
entsprechenden Antrag hier vorgelegt
nächste Rednerin ist Irene miralitsch
erste parlamentarische Geschäftsführerin
der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen und
ehemalige Polizeibeamtin
liebe Kollegen die Bundespolizei ist ein
Eckpfeiler und Garant für die innere
Sicherheit unseres Landes sie zu Stärken
auf hohem Niveau auszustatten und
einsatzbereit zu halten ist unser aller
Verpflichtung meine Damen und Herren
nicht zuletzt in diesen schwierigen
Zeiten von allgegenwärtigen Krisen und
dem Krieg in der Ukraine verdienen die
Beschäftigten der Bundespolizei unseren
besonderen Dank und Wertschätzung meine
Damen und Herren und deshalb hätte es
mich umso mehr gefreut wenn wir
inzwischen die Ruhe gehaltsfähigkeit der
Polizei Zulage wieder eingeführt hätten
genauso wie wir es auch um
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart haben
leider hängt der bereits fertige
Gesetzentwurf der Innenministerin noch
im Bundesfinanzministerium zur Freigabe
fest ich appelliere an dieser Stelle
aber auch ausdrücklich an unseren
Koalitionspartner es ist wichtig dass
wir in dieser wichtigen Frage
Vorankommen denn gerade für die
zahlreichen Beschäftigten der
Bundespolizei im mittleren Dienst wäre
es ein so wichtiges Signal in diesen
schwierigen Zeiten da dürfen wir Sie
nicht im Regen stehen lassen meine Damen
und Herren
und nun komme ich zu ihrem Antrag liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
sie haben ja durchaus ein paar
vernünftige Dinge aufgeschrieben aber
mit dem meisten was sie da vorschlagen
sind sie ja schon in der letzten
Wahlperiode krachend gescheitert und
nach diesem völlig verkorksten
Gesetzgebungsverfahren ist es gut dass
die Ampel jetzt anpackt was sie damals
verbockt haben nach fast 30 Jahren
Stillstand werden wir das
bundespolizeigesetz endlich novellieren
damit treffen wir eine
Richtungsentscheidung für die Zukunft
der Bundespolizei wir werden darauf
achten dass die Bundespolizei moderne
und vor allen Dingen rechts sicher
ausgestaltete Rechtsgrundlagen erhält so
wie es für ihre wichtige Arbeit
erforderlich ist
und dazu gehört auch die Debatte darüber
zu führen dass die Bundespolizei die
Zuständigkeit für die Bearbeitung von
Verbrechens Tatbeständen bekommt sie
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union
und das haben sie sich jetzt hier auch
schon öfter anhören müssen fordern
hingegen die Nutzung automatischer
Gesichtserkennung sie wollen die Quellen
TKÜ für die Bundespolizei und die
Wohnraumüberwachung damit laufen sie
nicht nur meilenweit am tatsächlichen
Bedarf vorbei sondern sie würden auch
noch einen ganzen Berg voller
verfassungsrechtlicher Unsicherheiten
schaffen was wir aber brauchen ist gut
ausgebildetes gut ausgestattetes
Personal das kriminalistisch arbeitet
und keine Rechtsunsicherheiten meine
Damen und Herren
ein sehr wichtiges Thema ist zudem eine
professionelle und vor allem
diskriminierungsfreie Arbeit der
Bundespolizei und seit Jahren wird
Deutschland auch unter der
unionsgeführten Bundesregierung von
europäischen Institutionen dazu
aufgefordert wirksam gegen das
sogenannte racial Profiling vorzugehen
und die Novelle des bundespolizegesetzes
bietet nun eine echte Chance dafür eben
mehr Rechtssicherheit für
Personenkontrollen zu schaffen und eben
gleichzeitig Diskriminierungen
vorzubeugen und hier möchten wir
zusammen mit unseren Koalitionspartnern
an der Entwicklung von alltagstauglichen
und praktikablen Lösungen arbeiten wie
zum Beispiel die flächendeckende
Ausstattung der Beamten und Beamten mit
bodycams die auch verlange noch
eingeschaltet werden oder die
Ausstellung von kontrollquittungen sind
wichtige Maßnahmen für die wir uns
einsetzen wollen und nein liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union um
uns allen hier ihre plattitüten zu
ersparen diese Maßnahmen drücken nicht
mangelndes Vertrauen in die Arbeit der
Polizei aus im Gegenteil weil wir
schaffen Vertrauen meine Damen und
Herren
denn die aller
meisten den Polizisten machen
eine
Arbeit und wir wollen Sie darin
unterstützen und ihnen die
Rechtsgrundlagen an die Hand geben die
sie für ein professionelles einschreiten
auch so dringend brauchen und wer immer
nur nichts tut ja und sagt die Polizei
macht immer alles richtig der zerstört
in Wahrheit das Vertrauen in diese so
wichtige Institution unserer
Gesellschaft und das muss sich dringend
ändern
deshalb ist es auch so wichtig dass wir
demnächst auch ein Gesetzentwurf zu
Schaffung eines unabhängigen
polizeibeauftragten vorlegen werden wir
wollen dadurch eine unabhängige
Ansprechperson für Polizistinnen und
Polizisten und für Bürgerinnen und
Bürger hier beim Deutschen Bundestag
schaffen aber auch dagegen polemisieren
sie ja immer gerne ja das Schreiben sie
ja auch in ihrem Antrag aber ihr
Konservativismus ist eben nach dem Motto
gestrickt einfach immer dasselbe sagen
egal wie die Welt sich verändert wir als
Ampel werden aber dafür sorgen dass sich
etwas ändert und zwar zum Positiven denn
es geht um eine Kultur des Vertrauens
und der Wertschätzung der wir uns
verpflichtet fühlen Vertrauen in die
Polizei Beamten und Beamten des Bundes
die wir mit neuen modernen Kompetenzen
ausstatten wollen Vertrauen der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in die
Sicherheitsbehörden unseres
demokratischen Rechtsstaats und
Wertschätzung die mehr ist als eine
hohle Phrase unsere Polizistinnen und
Polizisten brauchen kein Mitleid oder
Schulterklopfen sie verdienen
aufrichtige Anerkennung ihrer Arbeit die
sich in vielen Maßnahmen ausdrückt und
in diesem Sinne wünsche ich uns allen
eine gute und besinnliche Weihnachtszeit
denn in der Ruhe liegt die Kraft die wir
auch für die anstrengenden und die
anstehenden sicherheitspolitischen
Reformen Debatten so dringend brauchen
ganz herzlichen Dank
Irene mich jetzt die erste
parlamentarische Geschäftsführerin der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen hat hier
gesprochen zum Antrag der Unionsfraktion
zur Stärkung der Bundespolizei das
bleibt auch noch ein bisschen Thema auch
bei Stefan thomey der einer der
Parlamentarischen Geschäftsführer der
FDP-Fraktion ist
wenn man sich den Antrag der Union so
durchliest dann fühlt man sich
jedenfalls an ein paar Stellen als wäre
man in eine Kammer des Schreckens
grenzenlose überwachungs-
alle nur irgendwie denkbaren Befugnisse
hineinpacken würden und weitergeben
würden wenn man sie nur lassen würde
dabei sind ihre Fantasie irgendwie keine
Grenzen gesetzt von der Befugnis zum
Einsatz moderner Technik bis hin zur
Nutzung von Gesichtserkennung an
Bahnhöfen Flughäfen und hin zur Wohnraum
Überwachung und schließlich fast schon
erwartungsgemäß wie auch in Stichwort im
Theater die Befugnis zur
telegationsüberwachung sowie zu Befugnis
der sogenannten und der Online
Durchsuchung da fehlt nichts aus dem
Szenario aber
es ist eine Tat jetzt vieles dabei was
man sich in Bezug auf die Ausweitung von
bundespolizeilichen Befugnissen gerade
nicht wünschen würden denn der Feier den
fassungsstaat Macht von Eingriffe
Funknetzen und überwachungsbefugte sind
wirklich nur sehr sehr zurückhaltend und
maßvollen gebrauchen
zudem verkennen sie in ihrem Antrag den
Stellenwert die Möglichkeiten die
Chancen die Optionen eines unabhängigen
polizeibeauftragten den sie als
überflüssig acht in ihrem Antrag und so
macht ihr Antrag eines deutlich es ist
gut dass die FDP in der
Regierungsverantwortung mit ist mit den
Grünen und SPD denn mit uns ist eine
solchen rücksichtslosen und übrigens
auch weitestgehend unnötigen ein
Generalangriff auf die Bürgerrechte und
auch auf unsere IT-Sicherheit wie sie
hier Vorhaben gerade nicht geben mit
diesem Antrag wird die Union einer
vernünftigen Reform des
bundespolizeigesetzes nicht einmal im
Ansatz gerecht
ist auch wirklich interessant wie
selbstbewusst die Union hier die
Stärkung der Bundespolizei fordert denn
die wesentlichen Elemente des
bundespolizeigesetzes stammt aus dem
Jahr 1904 und 90 94 damals ist darüber
noch Bundesgrenzschutz und eigentlich
wollte auch die letzte große Koalition
des Gesetz modernisieren ist aber damit
dann im Jahr 2021 gescheitert nur zwei
Monate vor der Bundestagswahl das heißt
wenn Sie jetzt das Thema zum zu ihrem
Thema machen dann zeigen Sie woran sie
jetzt zuletzt eben noch stecken
geblieben sind werden Sie also am Ende
doch die Bundespolizei in ihrer
veralteten das ist Grundlage
zurückgelassen haben werden wir die
Modernisierung des Bundespräsident das
jetzt anpacken denn die Koalition hat
die Überarbeitung des Bundespolizei
Gesetzes zu einem der wichtigen Vorhaben
gemacht die wollen für eine gute
Personal und Sachausstattung sorgen und
vor allem auch den Zustand der
Liegenschaften verbessern und den Abbau
von Überstunden angehen vor allem der
Zustand vieler vieler Liegenschaften die
Bundespolizei gerade in Bahnhöfen nutzt
ist wirklich für die Polizeibeamtinnen
und Beamten untragbar wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass die notwendige Ausstattung
und angemessene Unterbringung
gewährleistet wird und ein letzten Punkt
will ich noch anfügen denn wir halten es
als FDP-Fraktion für einen wichtigen
Punkt die Kompetenzen der Bundespolizei
in Bezug auf Rückführungen dazu Stärken
wo Bundespolizei Beamte in ihrem
Zuständigkeitsbereich vor allem an
Bahnhöfen den unrechtmäßigen Aufenthalt
einer Person feststellen und dann sollte
sie auch für Rückführung zuständig sein
das sind
Zuständigkeitsfragen zwischen Bund und
Ländern zu klären aber es ist jedenfalls
Sinn
und auch notwendig dass da wo
ausweisepflichtig Ausländer angegriffen
werden auch die Bundespolizei wo sie sie
andere für Rückführung sorgen kann das
ist noch ein Punkt den wir angehen
wollen ansonsten werden wir dieses Thema
im nächsten Jahr beherzt angehen vielen
Dank und in allen frohe Weihnachten
guten Start ins neue Jahr
Stefan aus der FDP-Fraktion einer von ja
fast allen die hier schöne Weihnachten
wünschen am Ende ihrer Rede es ist ja
der letzte Sitzungstag in diesem Jahr
mutmaßlich jedenfalls Silke launert
jetzt für die Unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren
alles reden ist sinnlos wenn das
Vertrauen fehlt Worte des Philosophen
Kafka die zum Ausdruck bringen worauf es
am Ende wirklich ankommt nicht
ausschweifende reden betreuerungen
Versprechungen sondern schlichtweg auf
eins Vertrauen und nur derjenige welche
das Gefühl hat dass ihm vertraut wird
der fühlt sich auch wertgeschätzt und
vom Vertrauen der Bundesregierung unsere
Polizei in all die Männer und Frauen die
unsere Sicherheit garantieren Tag und
Nacht 24 Stunden am Tag 365 Tage im Jahr
da muss ich sagen spüre ich eher weniger
werden es im Koalitionsvertrag noch so
toll hieß schöne Worte die Wertschätzung
für unsere Polizistinnen und Polizisten
drücken sich aus auch durch eine gute
Personal und Sachausstattung den Zustand
der Liegenschaften den Abbau von
Überstunden und wieder Einführung der
Polizei Zulage aus wie sie die Realität
aus wir kennen dass sie die
Vollzugsbeamten stärken wollen und dann
nicht gekürzt haben pauschal mit diesen
1,5%. dafür haben wir uns auch
ausgesprochen dass erkennen wir an
allerdings trifft natürlich die
Einkommen 5% in der Verwaltung und da
hören wir Stimmen die sagen das macht
uns den Laden kaputt weil wir gerade
natürlich in den letzten Jahren viel
ausgebaut haben und diese Einsparung
wäre drastisch wir haben Sachen mit den
Kürzungen wir haben die geplante
Kennzeichnungspflicht also von
Bürgernähe das ist ja abstrus aber das
war ja jemand anders der diesen
Begriffen den Zusammenhang gebraucht hat
wir haben die Pläne zu Ernennung eines
Polizeibeamten ja interessant was
Wertschätzung ist und es ist eben nicht
so wie Frau mihalic sagt dass das nichts
mit Vertrauen zu tun hat ich kann Ihnen
sagen ich unterhalte mich auch ich war
letzte Woche erst bei meiner
Bundespolizei nicht auf die Soldaten auf
die Polizisten die Reden in der
vorhergehenden gezeigt fast alle
Beiträge auf links grün haben die
Polizisten angegriffen wie wichtig ist
die dadurch genau zu kontrollieren und
die vielen schwarzen Schafe zu filtern
das ist genau das Gegenteil von
Wertschätzung
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen gibt es
nicht zu null Unterricht des kostet
54.000 Männer und Frauen und deshalb so
bitter es ist ein schwarzes Schaf zu
haben das ist nicht in schuld war so
sehr müssen wir die anderen 54.000
Männer und Frauen der Bundespolizei
sehen die jeden Tag ihren Kopf hinhalten
bereit sind in Gefahrensituationen ja
vielleicht sogar ihr Leben zu lassen und
für diese Person trägt die
Bundesregierung die Verantwortung und
diese Person haben unser Vertrauen unser
Wertschätzung verdient wir brauchen sie
die Rückendeckung die diese brauchen
haben wir in der letzten Periode gezeigt
auch hier wieder Frau mihalic 16 Jahre
nichts gemacht haben sie letzte Periode
geschlafen kurz Zusammenfassung 8.300
neue Stellen Erhöhung umfasst ein
fünftelungserhöhung 10% Polizeizulage
ein
stiegs stellt und sagt hohle Phrasen 16
ja nichts gemacht er hat wirklich
offensichtlich nicht aufgepasst
das Signal ist klar dass wir ausgesendet
haben
wir sehen welche wichtige Aufgabe er für
uns alle erledigt wie vielen Dank Herr
Gritsch dass sie das mal angesprochen
haben sie waren der einzige die 450
Bundespolizisten die in dem Einsatz
lässt der Woche aktiv dabei waren und
nämlich ihren Job gemacht haben und
unsere Demokratie verteidigt haben wir
sehen was ihr leistet wir stehen an
eurer Seite wir unterstützen euch und
vor allem wir vertrauen euch und das ist
eben genau das Gegenteil was die Ampel
macht wir hören immer nur was alles
falsch läuft wie man kontrollieren muss
wie man alle möglichen Leute rausbringen
muss schaffen sie nötigen
Rahmenbedingungen machen sie den Weg
frei für die Erweiterung der
Zuständigkeit der Bundespolizei machen
sie den Weg frei für die Befugnisse zu
Telekommunikationsüberwachung quentica
online Durchsuchung kurz um schenken Sie
unseren Leuten bei der Bundespolizei
vertrauen
sie haben es verdient
nächste Rednerin für die SPD-Fraktion
Simona Kos
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren die Polizei
weiter Bundespolizei weiter stärken so
der Titel des Antrags der Union und wer
mag dem widersprechen
was die Ampelkoalition für die Stärkung
der Bundespolizei tut und im Haushalt
223 verankert ist haben wir schon von
einigen Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Koalition gehört ich möchte es trotzdem
noch mal wiederholen 1.000 neue Stellen
acht neue Stellen für dringend
gebrauchte sozialarbeitende um
Psychologinnen und Psychologen für die
aus- und Fortbildungszentren der
Bundespolizei
21,1 Millionen Euro für die Beschaffung
neuer Kontrolle und Streifenboote und
neuer mehrzweckbote der GSG 9
3,9 Millionen Euro für die Beschaffung
von Drohnen zum Schutz kritischer
Infrastruktur
die Ausstattung der Bundespolizei im
Haushalt 223 ist dank Ampelkoalition und
bundesinnenministerin Nancy Feser in
guten Händen
wir nehmen den Titel ihres Antrages
Ernst wir stärken die Bundespolizei in
diesem Jahr habe ich insgesamt drei Mal
den Standort Blumenberg der
Bundespolizei besucht zuletzt gemeinsam
am 11 November mit meinem Kollegen Uli
Grötsch die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
dort sind zuständig für den Grenzschutz
Migrationsarbeit an den Grenzen zu Polen
Österreich Tschechien und der Schweiz
und wir wissen meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren wie die Situation an
den Grenzen ist sie sind zuständig für
die Sicherung von Bahnhöfen und
Gleisanlagen für Einsätze zur
Unterstützung bei Versammlung in den
Bundesländern Berlin Brandenburg und
Sachsen sowie für Einsätze zu
Unterstützung des BKA unter anderem beim
G7 Gipfel
bei unserem Besuch waren wir tief davon
beeindruckt mit welchem großen
Engagement die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Bundespolizei unter schwierigen
Bedingungen ihre Arbeit leisten
falls es Sie interessiert werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
dann machen Sie sich doch einmal die
Mühe und schauen sich an und da welchem
Bedingungen die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Bundespolizei dort arbeiten müssen
sie werden Häuser in der Bausubstanz aus
den 80er Jahren vorfinden die den
Anforderungen die wir und sie an die
Bundespolizei Stellen nicht mehr gerecht
werden
werte Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
Union bevor sie jetzt mit dem Finger auf
die Ampel zeigen diese Rahmenbedingungen
herrschen dort in Blumberg seit Jahren
dringend wirklich dringend müssen jetzt
folgende Bauvorhaben umgesetzt werden
der Bau einer Befehlsstelle die
Bereitstellung eines führungsraums die
Erweiterung von Trainingsmöglichkeiten
neue Unterkünfte für die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und eine neue Mensa es gibt
einen Masterplan über 15 Jahre mit fünf
Bauabschnitten wichtig ist dass endlich
mit der konkreten Umsetzung begonnen
wird wir werden das jetzt in Angriff
nehmen was der Innenminister Seehofer
mit seinem bayerischen Blick
möglicherweise nicht hat sehen können
oder sehen wollen
wir werden und ich persönlich werde mich
dafür einsetzen den Standort so zu
ertüchtigen dass er einer modernen
Bundespolizei entspricht
ich danke allen Kolleginnen und Kollegen
in Zivil und den Uniform für ihr
Engagement und ihren Einsatz denn sie
leisten unter schwierigen Bedingungen
eine erstklassige Arbeit
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
wir schauen nach vorne wir packen an ich
danke Ihnen für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit und
wünsche Ihnen ein schönes Weihnachtsfest
und einen guten Rutsch
Simona Corus aus der SPD-Fraktion
Rednerin gewesen in dieser Debatte jetzt
kommt philipp am Tor aus der
Unionsfraktion ist uns Sprecher der
Unionsfraktion für
Staatsorganisation und
Staatsmodernisierung
die wir jetzt in der zurückliegenden
Stunde geführt haben über die
Bundespolizei die hat schon sehr sehr
deutlich gezeigt und ich hoffe dass das
viele Bundespolizisten in unserem Land
auch zur Kenntnis nehmen wo die
einzelnen Fraktionen dieses Parlaments
ihre Schwerpunkte setzen die einen wir
haben in den vergangenen Jahren dafür
gesorgt dass es ein beispiellosen
aufwuchs bei der Bundespolizei gab sie
haben stattdessen den
gesamtpersonalansatz der Bundespolizei
reduziert und man hat den Eindruck die
wichtigste zukunftsstelle für die
Bundespolizei in der Zukunft sind bei
ihnen nicht neue Einsatzhundertschaften
hier dringend bräuchte sondern ein
polizeibeauftragter liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen wir haben uns in den
vergangenen Jahren und tun es auch mit
dieser Debatte sehr klar dafür
eingesetzt dass die Bundespolizei
Instrumente und Befugnisse auf der Höhe
der Zeit bekommt statt neuer Befugnisse
und Instrumente gibt es von ihnen eine
Kennzeichnungspflicht für Polizisten und
Polizisten das ist zu wenig liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und man hat den
Eindruck in ihrem Vorträgen ist das
Hauptthema eine sogenannte bürgernahe
Bundespolizei das scheint ihr Wunsch zu
sein ich sage Ihnen das ist auch die
Realität in unserem Land eine Realität
die sie verkennen und das wichtigste
Ziel was es braucht ist eine
Bundespolizei die wirksam gegen
Straftäter und Extremisten vorgehen kann
und dafür braucht es unseren Antrag
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
nach einer wirklich beispiellosen
Erfolgsgeschichte der personellen
Stärkung die wir ja nicht nur alleine
sondern auch mit der SPD die sich zum
Teil daran ja nicht mehr erinnern kann
und glaubt in den letzten 16 Jahren alle
schlecht gewesen in dieser gemeinsamen
Erfolgsgeschichte haben wir dafür
gesorgt dass 54
000 Bundespolizisten unsere innere
Sicherheit stärken unsere Freiheit
verteidigen und diese Menschen brauchen
ein rechtlichen Instrumentenkasten auf
der Höhe der Zeit wir haben es gehört
das bundespolizeigesetz es ist 30 Jahre
alt es braucht ein Neuanlauf und ich
sage gerade Ihnen wo Sie uns immer
vorwerfen wir würden hier nur meckern
wir würden nur kritisieren wir haben
konkrete Vorschläge gemacht sie kündigen
nur an wo ist denn ihr Gesetzentwurf zum
Bundespolizei gesetzt liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen und
ich fände übrigens toll die
spatzenpfeifen das ja von den Dächern es
gibt ja den Referenten Entwurf wir haben
gehört der steckt jetzt im
Finanzministerium fest ist übrigens auch
ein tolles Zeichen vom Parlamentarismus
dass wir die Dinge irgendwo in der
Öffentlichkeit diskutiert finden aber
nicht hier im Parlament trotzdem wissen
wir natürlich was sie vorschlagen es ist
ungenügend Einführung von Tasern den
sogenannten Distanz elektroimpulsgeräten
Fehlanzeige quellt Telekommunikations
ein Überwachung Fehlanzeige online
Durchsuchung Fehlanzeige stattdessen
Kennzeichnungspflicht und
polizeibeauftragte liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ihr Entwurf trägt den Namen
Bundespolizei gesetzt ist in der Sache
aber keine notwendige Stärkung der
Bundespolizei liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen den
gibt es stattdessen von uns und ich will
Ihnen auch noch mal sagen sie fallen
insbesondere die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der SPD deutlich hinter dem
zurück was wir in der vergangenen
Wahlperiode auch gemeinsam beschlossen
haben das bundespolizeigesetz das im
Bundesrat gescheitert ist dass wir nicht
irgendwie meine unverbindliche
Willenserklärung der Union sondern es
war ein Beschluss dieses Parlaments und
es ist gescheitert auch maßgeblich an
der SPD an Boris Pistorius und am
Bundesrat liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das dürfen wir auch nicht vergessen und
Frau Feser ich sage ihm sie müssen dann
auch liefern und sollten dann im
Bundesrat auch dafür sorgen sich etwas
zuzutauen und jetzt nicht lieblos das
Bundespolizei Gesetz so auszugestalten
dass all die Dinge die eine
Zustimmungspflicht im Bundesrat auslösen
dass die alle gestrichen werden weil sie
es sich nicht zutrauen dort die
Ministerpräsidenten zu überzeugen und
ich finde wer andere Ministerpräsidenten
nicht überzeugen kann ein gutes die
Polizei gesetzt zu machen der sollte
auch selbst nicht das Amt der
Ministerpräsidentin anstreben das ist
bei Boris rein deutlich besser
aufgehoben frohe Weihnachten liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Weihnachtswünsche auch vom fachsprecher
für staatsorganisationen Philipp Amthor
aus der Unionsfraktion er war der
vorletzte Redner in dieser Debatte in
der es um die Bundespolizei geht und um
deren Stärkung da gibt es natürlich
unterschiedliche Vorstellungen auf der
einen wie auf der anderen Seite jetzt
noch mal Sebastian Fiedler für die
SPD-Fraktion
aber gar nicht auf alles eingehen können
was jetzt gerade aufgeräumt werden muss
lieber Kollege Amthor und die Kollegen
der Union ich empfinde das offen
gestanden auch als persönliche
Beleidigung ich habe mich jahrelang für
die Belange der Polizeibeamten
ehrenamtlich und hauptamtlich eingesetzt
und glauben Sie eigentlich die SPD und
die Ampelkoalition werden mit
Klammerbeutel gepudert ich bin kein
Ausnahme sondern ich rede hier für die
ampelfraktion für die fortschrittskirche
und natürlich stehen wir hinter unseren
Sicherheitsbehörden und nur weil sie ja
zu schaufensterantrag kurz vor
Weihnachten noch mal irgendwie
reinhängen und meinen jetzt noch mal das
gesamte Reportage der neuen oder Politik
reinigen zu müssen ist das sozusagen
kein Gegenpol sondern sie tun so als
stünde die Bundespolizei mit all ihren
vielfältigen Aufgaben viele sind schon
genannt worden Sicherung der Grenzen
Flughäfen Spezialeinheiten Hubschrauber
Wasserfahrzeuge paar tausend Leute die
Kripo Arbeit dort machen
Auslandseinsätze Botschaften werden
überwacht oder tun sie im Prinzip so als
Stunde das alles im luftleeren Raum und
ich finde jetzt auch schon bemerkenswert
wenn sie auf die Überstunden hinweisen
und ich guck mal auch gerade so nach
Hessen wissen Sie eigentlich wie viel
der Überstunden dadurch zustande kommen
dass die Bundespolizei die Ländern
unterstützen muss
wir haben ganzen Polizeibeamten in
Hessen warum müssen die denn da
hinfahren jedes Wochenende haben sie die
Überstunden mal abgefragt die auf dieses
Konto gehen also lassen Sie uns auch
über die Personalausstattung mal reden
und genauso verhält es sich hören Sie
lieber zu es ist nicht zu ihrem Nachteil
und genauso verhält es sich was
Befugnisse angeht die Länder hatten ja
gute Gründe und ich war zwar nicht dabei
weil ich höre Bayern sah irgendwie auch
da hatten sie die vergessen also war das
irgendwie 15:1 im Bundesrat gibt es da
jetzt so weh Tutus ich will vor allen
Dingen aber einen Punkt noch mal
herausstellen weil ich leider nicht so
viel Redezeit habe um alle Geschichten
aufzuräumen weil das ist mir tatsächlich
wichtig dass meine ich wirklich ernst
und das nehmen Sie sich mal zu Herzen
weil wir vorhin eine Debatte übers
Hinweisgeber Schutzgesetz geführt haben
und da steht im direkten zusammen
natürlich ist es gut und richtig so dass
das Vertrauen der Bevölkerung in die
Sicherheitsbehörden außerordentlich gut
ist aber ich wiederhole noch mal ein
Teil vom gerade das ist nicht in allen
Bevölkerungsschichten
unterhalten sie sich mal mit Familien
die eine Einwanderungsgeschichte haben
ich bin neulich auf einer Veranstaltung
gewesen nach dem Vorfall in Dortmund und
da sagen Ihnen Lehrerinnen und Lehrer
kleine Kinder haben Angst vor der
Polizei
nehmen sie das ernst und das können sie
nicht einfach wegwischen und sagen da
haben wir jetzt kein Problem oder nehmen
wir mal Durchschnittswert und da haben
wir nichts mit zu tun und spielen Sie
das um Himmels Willen nicht aus gegen
eine vermeintliche Position als sei das
gegen die Sicherheitsbehörde gerichtet
ich frage mich wirklich allen Ernstes wo
bleibt am Samstag zur Abschaffung der
werbeauftragten
wenn Sie das eigentlich das ist Quatsch
nichts anderes haben wir eigentlich vor
als Gegenargument sie müssten eine
Antrag einreichen sie wollen die
Werbeauftrag abschaffen wenn sie gegen
polizeibeauftragte sind dass sie haben
sich offenbar gar nicht damit
beschäftigt das ist vollkommener Unsinn
zum Thema Kennzeichnungspflicht ich bin
gelernter Kriminalbeamter wissen Sie
eigentlich dass jeder Kriminalbeamter
bei Ermittlungsakten auch gegen die
organisierte Kriminalität mit Vor- und
Nachname in Ermittlungsakte steht ist
ihnen das eigentlich klar wir reden doch
hier nur über pseudonymisierte
Kennzeichen versuchen Sie doch nicht die
ganze Polizei zu verunsichern
dass sich das Thema
Sicherheitsüberprüfung ist angesprochen
worden also was ich sagen will wir
müssen natürlich weiter dafür sorgen
dass das Vertrauen auch in allen Teilen
der Bevölkerung so groß ist wie ist das
im Durchschnitt ist das ist leider
Gottes noch ein Problem und dazu tun wir
ein ganzes Bündel von unterschiedlichen
Maßnahmen ich selbst habe eine gerade zu
abwegige Diskussion mit Horst Seehofer
darüber geführt ob wir den Wissenschaft
verbieten dürfen irgendwie die Polizei
zu untersuchen da kann ich mich noch
sehr gut daran erinnern also wir tun
sehr sehr viel Leben einerseits
natürlich die personelle Situation gut
auszustatten es ist alles schon auch
unter anderem von Comeback und anderen
gesagt worden technische Ausstattung die
Mittel sind aufgerüstet worden und
natürlich stehen wir mit allem was wir
haben hinter unseren Sicherheitsbehörden
und ich bin froh dass die
bundesinnenministerin auch dazu ein sehr
modernes
bundespolizeigesetz vorlegen wird
so liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
grüße sie alle und darf dann die
Aussprache schließen wir kommen zum
Antrag der Fraktion der cdu/csu auf
Drucksache 48/81 die Fraktion der CDU
CSU wünscht Abstimmung in der Sache die
Fraktionen SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und
FDP wünschen Überweisung und zwar
federführend an den Ausschuss für
Inneres und Heimat und mit beratend an
den Rechtsausschuss wir stimmen
natürlich wieder zuerst über den Antrag
auf Ausschuss Überweisungen ab ich frage
deshalb wer stimmt für die beantragte
Überweisung
das ist spd-bündnis 90 die Grünen FDP
und AFD wer stimmt da giegen das sind
die linke und die cdu/csu Enthaltung
keine damit ist die Überweisung
beschlossen und wir stimmen heute über
den Antrag auf Drucksache 48/81 in der
Sache nicht ab
dafür geht es jetzt weiter mit dem
nächsten Tagesordnungspunkt der die
Nummer 24 in dieser Sitzungswoche es
geht um Ehrenamt und Engagement wir
haben heute morgen schon ein ganz
interessantes Interview dafür zugeführt
mit gelind aus der SPD-Fraktion und
Volker Ulrich aus der Unionsfraktion das
geht darum wie auch in Zukunft
ehrenamtliches Engagement gefördert und
beibehalten werden kann Grundlage für
die Debatte jetzt hier im Parlament ist
ein Bericht der Bundesregierung der
vorherigen Bundesregierung muss man
sagen
ein Bericht der von einer unabhängigen
Kommission erstellt wurde eben Auftrag
des Bundesministeriums für Familie
Senioren Frauen und Jugend und danach
mit einer Stellungnahme der
Bundesregierung versehen jeder Bericht
der ist es inzwischen der dritte
übrigens jeder Bericht beleuchtet
besondere Schwerpunkte des
bürgerschaftlichen Engagements im Fokus
des dritten Berichts steht junges
Engagement im digitalen Zeitalter und
der erste Redner ist Sven Lehmann
Parlamentarischer Staatssekretär im
Innenministerium zuhören rund 29
Millionen Menschen engagieren sich in
Deutschland jeden Tag ehrenamtlich 29
Millionen Menschen das ist eine
beeindruckende Zahl und all diese
Menschen sind Motor und sind Herz
unserer Demokratie ihr Engagement ist
der Kit der unsere Gesellschaft
zusammenhält und jeder und jedem
einzelnen von diesen 29 Millionen
Menschen möchte ich im Namen der
Bundesregierung aber sicher auch im
Namen des gesamten Hauses beim
aufrichtigen Dank aussprechen
all den all den Freiwilligen die
Hunderttausenden geflüchteten Menschen
aus der Ukraine die Ankunft in
Deutschland erleichtern all den
engagierten die in Sportvereinen in der
Freiwilligen Feuerwehr oder in
Kirchengemeinden jeden Tag für andere da
sind all denen die täglich Zusammenhalt
Leben erst recht in diesen
herausfordernden Zeiten der vorliegende
dritte engagementbericht ist einer von
insgesamt fünf berichten und das Thema
dieses Berichtes ist hochaktuell junges
Engagement im digitalen Zeitalter drei
Ergebnisse sind dabei zentral erstens
die Digitalisierung eröffnet neue Wege
sich einzubringen und zu engagieren
zweitens digitale Plattformen werden
dabei immer wichtiger und drittens
digitales Engagement schafft auch mehr
Flexibilität zu nutzen etwa mehr als 40%
der Jugendlichen auch oder sogar
ausschließlich digitale Medien für ihr
Engagement der Bericht zeigt uns also
wichtige Trends auf und er gibt uns aber
auch auch einen ganzen Strauß an
Aufgaben mit wir sollen Menschen und
Vereine beim Einstieg in das digitale
Engagement besser unterstützen wir
sollen helfen nicht digitales und
digitales Engagement besser miteinander
zu verbinden und wir sollen das
Engagement von Jugendlichen stärker
würdigen
wir im Bundesfamilienministerium was ja
auch das engagementministerium ist
wollen den 29 Millionen engagierten den
Rücken stärken zum Beispiel zusammen mit
der Stiftung für Engagement und Ehrenamt
seit ihrer Gründung vor zwei Jahren hat
die Stiftung bereits mehr als 7000
Verein Organisationen mit rund 70
Millionen Euro unterstützt außerdem
arbeiten wir gerade einen neuen
engagementstrategie damit Engagement so
einfach wie möglich gemacht wird und
gerade in dieser Woche haben wir einen
weiteren Meilenstein erreicht die
Bundesregierung hat das erste Demokratie
fördergesetz auf den Weg gebracht
mit diesem Gesetz schaffen wir mehr
Planungssicherheit für diejenigen die
sich täglich für andere und für unsere
Werte einsetzen ihre wichtige Arbeit
stellen wir auf eine stabile und
nachhaltige Grundlage denn je mehr
Menschen sich gesellschaftlich
engagieren desto stärker ist der
Zusammenhalt in der Gesellschaft und
desto stärker ist die Wehrhaftigkeit
gegen die die unsere Demokratie
gefährden wollen Engagement zu fördern
ist also ein aktiver Beitrag Demokratie
und Zusammenhalt zu stärken deswegen
danke ich den Experten Experten für
diesen wertvollen Bericht und freue mich
jetzt sehr auf die Debatte dazu vielen
Dank
das Wort erhält Ralf Edelhäuser für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der dritte
engagementbericht namens Zukunft
Zivilgesellschaft junges Engagement
digitalen Zeitalter ist für mich zu
allerersten Mal ein Grund ja für
freudigen Optimismus denn er zeigt dass
oftmals ja die Jugend irgendwie als
orientierungslos oder schwer zu
begeistern bezeichnet wird dass die
durchaus engagiert sind und auch ihr
Leben entsprechend meistern denn etwa
zwei Drittel etwa zwei Drittel der 14
bis 27-Jährigen geben an dass sie
gesellschaftlich einbringen und ich
finde diese Zahl wirklich beeindruckend
und deswegen glaube ich im ganzen Saal
hier werden Sie mir zustimmen weil
einfach mal Danke sagen an diese
Jugendlichen und junge Erwachsenen
und nicht erst seit der corona-zeit ist
es ehrenamtlich Engagement hat sich das
irgendwo geändert und verändert und
gerade auch bei den jungen Menschen es
ist digitale geworden und deswegen wirkt
sich das natürlich auch auf das Ehrenamt
aus es gibt neue Formate es gibt neue
Strukturen nun ist es aber so dass diese
aktive Mitgestaltung an der Gesellschaft
und auch an den relevanten Themen die
sich in unserer Zeit ergeben dass diesen
jungen Menschen das ein großes Anliegen
ist da müssen aber auch die
Rahmenbedingungen schaffen was die
Anforderungen der engagierten betrifft
und nicht dass ich die engagierten an
die Anforderungen irgendwie anpassen
müssen das glaube sie ganz wichtige
Geschichte und deswegen glaube ich auch
dass die Anpassung der Wahrnehmung
dieses Ehrenamtes ganze wichtige
Geschichte ist denn in den letzten
Jahren
hatten wir eigentlich nur das physische
Ehrenamt wir haben es gehört eine
Vereinen in den Verbänden in der
Feuerwehren in den Kirchen der hat sich
alles abgespielt aber jetzt hat sich das
verlagert in die digitale Welt für mich
gehört aber ganz klar beides zusammen
das reale Ehrenamt aber auch das
digitale Ehrenamt und das muss man auch
entsprechend stärken die Jugend von
heute
die Jugend von heute will Verantwortung
übernehmen das will sie aber nicht mehr
irgendwie ein festen Strukturen und
starren Strukturen mehrmals so in einem
Verein war mit Satzungen
Satzungsänderungen mit Notar und so
weiter neben diesen Formalismus will die
junge Leute über die wollen Optionen
haben die wollen was ausprobieren und
das wollen sie auch im Ehrenamt und das
ist gut so und das finde ich richtig gut
weil das Projekt bezogen einfach immer
wichtiger wird und sie wollen Sie mit
unserer Gesellschaft auseinandersetzen
sie wollen sich da auch einbringen und
sie wollen aber auch nicht darauf
verzichten wir als Gesellschaft können
auch nicht darauf verzichten dass sich
die jungen Leute einbringen und dann
müssen wir als Parlament auch darauf
reagieren können
was ist dazu zu sagen was ist es was was
muss man gemacht werden die Definition
zum Beispiel vom gemeinnützigen Zweck in
der Abgabenordnung das muss geändert
werden das muss angepasst werden auf die
neuen Formate die wir hier auch in der
heutigen Zeit eben sehen wir brauchen
mehr Kompetenzzentren die bundesweit
beraten und entsprechend vernetzen um
Synergien zu schaffen aber auch um
irgendwelche Hemmschwellen dies noch
vielleicht im digitalen Engagement gibt
auch zur herabzusetzen und einfach zu
verringen und das sieht aber auch das
bestehende Vereine und Verbände die es
in der heutigen Zeit der schon seit
vielen vielen Jahren gibt es die die
sich auf diese Digitalisierung
eingelassen haben mich einfach mal den
Bayerischen Landessportverband oder
einfach Vereine die gerade auch bei der
corona-pandemie hier umgestellt haben
die haben ja quasi ein Quantensprung
gemacht hin nur vom Sportverein hier die
haben was online gemacht die man
Quantensprung gemacht und das glaube ich
ganz gut die haben das einfach auch
schon in der Realität vollzogen und
deswegen müssen wir alle zusammen diese
Bedingungen für die Wahrnehmung von
digitalen Ehrenamt und Engagement auch
stärken und schaffen und zwar im
ländlichen Raum wie auch in den Städten
und Gemeinden dazu brauchen wir stabiles
Datennetz dazu brauchen wir aber auch
ein ordentlichen Bildungsgrad egal auf
welche Schule das wir uns bewegen das
ist wichtig dass wir die Leute darauf
vorbereiten dass die Kompetenzen
schaffen und das ist dann auch für die
jungen Leuten in der Zukunft so
weitergeht und die haben viele
Einschränkungen in der Vergangenheit
gehabt da war dann aber auch dass das
Jugendzentrum die Jugendhäuser haben wir
neue Wege gesucht ihr auch Neues
ausprobiert und es auch umgestellt und
umgesetzt und das glaube ich ist der
ganze entscheidende Geschichte das ist
so geklappt hat und jetzt geht es darum
dass die Digitalisierung auch im
Ehrenamt breiteren Raum einnimmt das ist
überfällig wir können stolz sein dass
die Jugend das schon gemacht hat dass
sie da dabei ist dass sie sich einbringt
und dafür müssen wir sagen dass wir
diese jungen Leute nicht verlieren wir
brauchen jeden das müssen ausbauen egal
ob digital oder auch im Mittelalter
leben vielen herzlichen Dank schöne
Weihnachten
als nächstes erhält Ariane Fischer das
Wort für die SPD-Fraktion
[Musik]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Werte
Demokraten Liebe engagierte mit
Erlaubnis der Präsidentin zitiere zieht
zitiere ich Regine Hildebrandt sag mir
nicht dass es nicht geht sag mir wird
das
das zivilgesellschaftliche Engagement in
Deutschland verändert sich mit dem Fokus
junges Engagement im digitalen Zeitalter
hat sich der dritte engagementbericht
befasst er zeigt auf dass Engagement im
Umbruch ist es wird in Teilen spontaner
agiler und digitaler auch in der
Vereinsarbeit durch die durch die
Digitalisierung entstehen neue Formen
des Engagements
basisdemokratische Bewegungen ohne feste
Struktur aber mit großer politischer
Kraft jedoch ohne Rechtsform damit
fallen Sie aus unseren förderkulissen
weitgehend heraus unsere
Förderinstrumente sind nämlich momentan
auf eine analoge Welt ausgerichtet
unsere Instrumente passen also ich
möchte sagen noch nicht zum realen und
künftigen Engagement übrigens nicht nur
von jungen Menschen
jetzt ist also die Frage wird in Zukunft
geht und wie die wie ein Kollege neulich
auf dem Podium desillusionieren wie ich
fand einwarf er ändern Sie die Zehn
Gebote als die bundeshaushaltsordnung
wir stecken da wohl in einem Dilemma
und 29 Millionen Menschen wir haben das
schon gehört engagieren sich
ehrenamtlich davon sind rund sechs
Millionen unter 30 Jahre alt ihr
Engagement ist anders jedenfalls
teilweise wir kommen wir aber zu einem
einfachen handhabbaren
Instrumentenkoffer der staatlichen
Unterstützung der den Bedarfen der
engagierten auch dient die Koalition
steht im staatblock um in diesem Sinne
bis Ende 2024 die engagementstrategie
des Bundes neu aufzulegen
darin fordert der
unterausschussbürgerschaftliches
Engagement neben den Ministerien dem
engagementnetzwerk BBE und der
Bundesstiftung DCE eine gestaltende
Rolle ein denn wir Parlamentarier sind
in unseren Wahlkreisen an den realen
Bedarfen vor Ort nah dran die
Ehrenamtlichen sagen uns es zu
bürokratisch ist zu kompliziert viel
Aufwand es geht um Fragen von
förderperiodenversicherungen Haftungen
Gemeinnützigkeit oder Fahrtkosten für
Vereine finden sich weniger Vorstände
Menschen wollen sich kurzfristiger in
Projekten oder spontan in der
Katastrophenhilfe engagieren und
Engagement immer noch privilegiert weil
sich zum Beispiel ärmere Familien den
Freiwilligendienst des Kindes den Laptop
oder auch die Fahrzeug Jugendkonferenz
schlicht nicht leisten können
wir wollen deshalb das nicht nur
Verbände sondern engagierte und vor
allem noch nicht engagierte die
Strategie aktiv mitgestalten können in
dezentralen Veranstaltungsformaten und
auf der bereits freigeschalteten
Online-Plattform an der alle mitmachen
können
die Zivilgesellschaft ist eine tragende
Säule der Demokratie und wird immer
stärker eine Zukunftsfrage für die
Stabilität von Staat und Gesellschaft
sein dort wird Demokratie positiv erlebt
als Gegengewicht zur Ohnmacht Hass und
wie wir kürzlich erst erlebt haben
Umsturz Fantasien
digitalaktive junge Menschen fühlen sich
politisch und gesellschaftlich wirksamer
gerade im ländlichen Raum wird auch das
digitale Engagement als Alternative
vielleicht fehlende reale
Beteiligungsmöglichkeiten erlebt
so wie wir die Demokratie
Entschuldigung wie wir die wehrhafte
Demokratie mit Demokratie fördergesetz
absichern müssen wir auch das
zivilgesellschaftliche Engagement in
Zukunft mit einem engagementfördergesetz
flankieren
wir liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
können eine lebendige Partnerschaft
zwischen Staat Wirtschaft und
Zivilgesellschaft mit direkten
zukunftsweisend flexiblen und
unbürokratischen Instrumenten
ermöglichen die Bundes-
nächste Rednerin ist für die
afd-fraktion gerrituy
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
der dritte Engagement Bericht handelt
von engagierten Jugendlichen und im
Internet und Überraschung die Jugend
nutzt gerne das Internet und sie nutzt
das heutige gelegentlich auch für
Engagement ein neues Wort dass das
frühere Ehrenamt einschließt und das ist
erweitert um spontanes und weitgehend
unorganisiertes Engagement Prototyp
dafür sind die Fridays for future Hüpfer
die sich bei der Ampel großer
Beliebtheit erfreuen dabei wird
unterstellt dass diese und ähnliche
Gruppen für einen guten Zweck eintreten
im Bericht wird dafür dass politisch
korrekte Wort ziviles Engagement genutzt
und falls es noch nicht wussten es gibt
auch und ziviles Engagement der Prototyp
dafür wiederum ist die querdenkerszene
man spricht auch von dunklem Engagement
anders als die Hüpfer gehören die
Querdenker freut sich auch nicht zur
Zivilgesellschaft sondern zur sondern
zur unzivilen Gesellschaft
diese Worte sind sicherlich sehr bewusst
gewählt denn die Linken argumentieren
seit Jahrzehnten das ist unsere Sprache
ist die unser Denken bestimmt und was
mit unanfängt ist eigentlich immer
schlecht aus unserer Sicht müssten wir
dann formulieren was die Ampel macht ist
unpolitik zumindest ist sie und zivil
denn sie schadet ja mehrheitlich unseren
Bürgern
aber ganz offenbar zählt aus ampelsicht
längst nicht mehr jeder Bürger zur
Zivilgesellschaft das mutet wirklich
schon
so also die Jugend nutzt gerne das
Internet für gesellschaftliches
Engagement sie zeichnet auch schnell mal
einen Shitstorm der dann schnell auch
unzivil werden kann es soll natürlich
nur das zivile Jugendliche Engagement
und unterstützt und gefördert werden
dafür steht bereits eine Stiftung bereit
die jährlich 30 Millionen Euro vergeben
kann meine Damen und Herren wir alle
wissen dass die Tugend der Politik nicht
der Anstand ist sondern die
Angepasstheit wollen wir die jetzt
wirklich auch ins Ehrenamt tragen es
liegt nur ein verdammt schmaler Grad
dazwischen ehrenamtliche
uneigennützig in ihrem Tun zu
unterstützen oder sie samt Ehrenamt zu
kapern und für staatszwecke zu
missbrauchen
indem man sie anfüttert und auf diese
Weise allmählich abhängig macht vom
Staat und dann vielleicht die
Anforderung für die Unterstützung
hochschreibt vielleicht müssen unsere
jungen engagierten dann erstmal unser
neues Glaubensbekenntnis ablegen ich
glaube an den menschengemachten
Klimawandel oder ich gelobe mit all
meiner Kraft künftig gegen Rechts zu
kämpfen können sich nicht vorstellen
dann haben sie sich noch nicht mit dem
neuen Demokratie fördergesetz
beschäftigt mit diesem Instrument soll
zukünftig sogar nachhaltig also
dauerhaft belohnt werden was gegen
Rechts ist
die in ampelkreisen geschätzte
Aktivistin annetta Khane schreibt bei
der Bundeszentrale für politische
Bildung ich zitiere einer der Gründe für
das dunkelste Kapitel der deutschen
Geschichte und ihrer verheerenden Folgen
der Siegeszug des Nationalsozialismus
und damit für Krieg und Holocaust war
ohne Zweifel die Schwäche der
Zivilgesellschaft der deutschen
Zivilgesellschaft das zivile unterlag
die Gesellschaft mit samt ihren Eliten
wandte sich dem Nationalsozialismus zu
und wurde zum Teil seines Systems Zitat
Ende wurde zum Teil des staatsansystems
meine Damen und Herren das war nicht nur
damals verheerend das ist immer
gefährlich deswegen brauchen wir auch
keine angepasste Zivilgesellschaft
sondern genau das Gegenteil eine
wehrhafte Zivilgesellschaft die sich
nicht staatlich vereinnahmen lässt eine
Gesellschaft die die Bürger nicht einmal
mehr spaltet in Zivil und zivilen eine
wirklich inklusive Bürgergesellschaft
also danke
[Applaus]
für die FDP-Fraktion erhält das Wort
Martin Gassner Herz
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren schade dass wir so eine
Rede zu diesem tollen Thema gerade eben
hören mussten
für uns Freie Demokraten sind die
Teilhabe an der Gesellschaft deren
Mitgestaltung und ihr Zusammenhalt
Ausdruck stolzer Bürgerlichkeit sie
gehören zu einer selbstbestimmten und
freien Zivilgesellschaft und sind
entscheidend für unsere Lebensqualität
das Engagement ist so vielfältig wie die
Themen die unsere Gesellschaft prägen
von Sport soziales und Kultur bis hin zu
Umwelt Gesundheit und Sicherheit in der
blaulichtfamilie und vieles vieles mehr
mit Blick auf die Zukunft der
Zivilgesellschaft sind Mitwirkungen und
Einbindung gerade junger Menschen
besonders wichtig dazu gehört
insbesondere wie dies auch aus dem
Bericht hervorgeht das Potenzial von
digitalen Lösungen zur Stärkung des
Ehrenamts auszuschöpfen dieses Potenzial
wurde durch die vorherigen
Bundesregierung fast kaum unterstützen
ein Beispiel hierfür ist das Fehlen eine
Anwendungssoftware vielen Dank für die
erleichterte steuerabführung für
zivilgesellschaftliche Organisationen
genau da wollen wir anpacken und für
Lösungen sorgen die Bundesregierung hat
eine digitalstrategie entwickelt Teil
dieses Strategie ist die vernetzte
Gesellschaft so soll unter anderem bis
2025 in Deutschland die
Zivilgesellschaft durch die Initiative
gestärkt und neue ki-projekte
angeschoben werden außerdem so ein
Beratungs- und Informationszentren für
KI wie das zvki ausgebaut und neu
geschaffen werden darüber hinaus planen
wir durch das Bundesprogramm Demokratie
leben jene Initiativen und Akteure zu
stärken die digitale Kompetenzen und an
Engagement gegen Hass im Netz fördern
aber auch mit der National
engagementstrategie die heute schon
öfters angesprochen wurde die aktuell
von uns gemeinsam mit der
Zivilgesellschaft erarbeitet wird so
dass Ehrenamt von seinen Fesseln gelöst
werden
eine gute Nachricht ist auch das haben
wir heute schon mehrfach gehört
dass es sich aus dem Bericht ableiten
lässt dass junges Engagement hoch ist
und da ist und viel mitwirkt
insbesondere Menschen erfinden
zahlreiche neue digitale Formate wodurch
ein neues engagementfeld entsteht
allerdings profitieren engagierte von
diesen Vorteilen nur dann wenn Sie auch
die Möglichkeit haben es tatsächlich in
Anspruch zu nehmen besonders
Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner von
ländlichen Regionen werden immer noch
von den Vorteilen des digitalen Wandels
wegen schleppenden Netzausbau in
Deutschland ausgeschlossen
genau deshalb legen wir beispielsweise
auf die breitbandfinanzierung noch was
oben drauf wir werden so 2023 beinauts
dreifache ausreichend im Vergleich zu
dem was 2021 noch gelungen ist meine
Damen und Herren Ehrenamt bedeutet dass
Menschen aus freien Stücken und Liebe
zum Nächsten füreinander da sind und
gemeinsam Berge versetzen ich finde ein
weihnachtliches Thema kann es eigentlich
nicht geben
in diesem Sinne wünsche ich Ihnen
besinnliche Festtage und einen
erholsamen Jahresausklang im Kreise
Ihrer Liebsten vielen Dank
auch Martin Gessner Herz vergisst nicht
hier dem Abgeordneten und ihren Familien
frohe Weihnachtstage zu wünschen und
einen guten Rutsch aber soweit sind die
Abgeordneten noch gar nicht stehen noch
einige Tagesordnungspunkte an bis heute
Mittag ca 15 Uhr auch wenn es heute
relativ geschmeidig voran geht also gar
keine Verzögerung bislang im Ablauf
haben wir aber erstmal Türkei aus der
Linksfraktion 2020 offiziell den
Familienministerium vorgelegt wurde erst
drei Jahre später findet die Debatte im
Bundestag dazu statt das verdeutlicht
die mangelnde Wertschätzung der
Bundesregierung gegenüber den rund 29
Millionen ehrenamtlich engagierten
Menschen in unserer Gesellschaft
den Menschen die sich tagtäglich neben
Beruf Familie und anderen
Verpflichtungen in vielen Bereichen
ehrenamtlich engagieren gilt mein großer
Dank
vielen Dank auch an die
Sachverständigenkommission die diesen
Bericht verfasst hat ohne das
bürgerschaftliche Engagement würde so
einiges in Deutschland nicht mehr laufen
beispielsweise die ehrenamtliche
Flüchtlingshilfe ohne sie hätte der
Staat bei der Aufnahme von ukrainischen
Kriegsflüchtlingen voll versagt
Defizite in der Erfüllung der
öffentlichen Aufgaben sollten aber nicht
dauerhaft durch das Ehrenamt und
Freiwilligendienste kompensiert werden
im dritten engagementbericht geht es um
die Zukunft der Zivilgesellschaften
nämlich jungges Engagement im digitalen
Zeitalter über 43 Prozent der Befragten
jungen jungen engagierten beschreiben
sich als digital engagierte dadurch
verändern sich die Rahmenbedingungen des
Ehrenamts besonders das Thema soziale
Ungerechtigkeit im digitalen Engagement
von Jugendlichen sollte uns allen zu
denken geben
[Applaus]
laut dem Bericht sind 47 Prozent der
HauptschülerInnen deutlich
seltener gesellschaftlich engagiert als
Gymnasiastinnen mit 73 Prozent außerdem
mangelt es deutlich mehr
HauptschülerInnen an Medienkompetenz als
Gymnasiasten im Bericht wird belegt dass
die Digitalisierung die bestehenden
Formen der sozialen Ungerechtigkeit
nicht durchbrechen kann deshalb
appelliere ich an die Bundesregierung
die engagementstrategie muss gezielt für
benachteiligte Jugendliche angepasst
werden
vor allem muss die Medienkompetenz der
Jugendlichen gestärkt werden hierfür
sind dringende Investitionen in die
digitale Infrastruktur der Schulen und
der Jugendeinrichtungen notwendig und
nicht zuletzt die die Kürzungen die wir
auch hier im Familienministerium
mitverfolgt haben
Engagement von Jugendlichen bedeutet
Mitbestimmung und trägt zu
demokratischer Bildung bei die
Digitalisierung muss hier als eine
Chance begriffen werden um die
demokratische Teilhabe für alle
Jugendlichen zu ermöglichen vielen Dank
[Applaus]
aus der Linksfraktion spricht unter
anderem die Hilfe für Flüchtlinge aus
der Ukraine an die viel von Freiwilligen
und Ehrenamtlern geleistet wurde auch
die Tafeln muss man in diesem
Zusammenhang noch mal erwähnen muss eine
sehr stark gestiegene Nachfrage gegeben
hat in den vergangenen Monaten und
entsprechenden Personalbedarf Emilia
fester für Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen Veränderung des Ehrenamts während
der corona-pandemie und auch von neuen
Formen von Engagement zum Beispiel in
der klimagerechtigkeitsbewegung was er
aber noch nicht verrät und auch nicht
verraten kann ist inwiefern sich
Engagement seit dem Kriegsbeginn erneut
verändert hat denn
Engagement entwickelt sich stetig fort
wenn die Welt sich verändert dann
verändert sich auch das Engagement und
das geht aber auch umgekehrt wenn das
Engagement sich verändert dann verändert
sich die Welt und das wohl aktuellste
und gewaltigste Beispiel dafür ist die
Revolution der mutigen Frauen und Männer
in Iran natürlich können wir uns nicht
mit vergleichen und doch steckt im Kern
genau das drin was alles Engagement
gemeinsam hat Engagement das ist das
wofür unser Herz absetztes lohnjobs oder
der Familie schlägt das ist das
Einsetzen für etwas was uns in dieser
Gesellschaft etwas bedeutet ob es der
eigene Sportverein ist in dem wir
zusammenkommen die Freiwillige Feuerwehr
oder das seenotrettungsschiff um unsere
Mitmenschen zu helfen der demokratische
proteststzug für das eigene Recht auf
Zukunft ob auf der kinderkrankenstation
im Altersheim in Sprachkursen in der
Schülervertretung bei der Tafel in
Museen im Netz die Orte für Engagement
sind zahllos vielfältig und so
unterschiedlich und doch haben
engagierte eben alle eins Gemeinden sie
stützen unser Zusammenleben wollen im
Kleinen wie großen etwas Gutes beitragen
doch an dieser Stelle von mir noch
einmal herzlichen Dank dafür
das Schöne ist dass Engagement nicht nur
der Gesellschaft etwas gibt sondern auch
denen die es ausführen sich einzusetzen
und stark zu machen ist gerade für die
vielen jungen Menschen die sich
engagieren eine riesiger Teil ihres
Wachstumsprozesses es sensibilisiert für
gesellschaftliche Herausforderungen
stärkt die Selbstverantwortung zeigt
ihnen dass sie wirksam sein und etwas
verändern können
maßgeblich dafür ist aber ihre
intrinsische Motivation und deswegen ist
es mir wichtig dass sie jetzt auch noch
einmal betonen zu betonen ein soziales
Pflichtjahr wird junge Menschen nicht
langfristig zu engagierten DemokratInnen
machen es wird unsere Gesellschaft nicht
in ihrem Zusammenhalt stärken und auch
den Fachkräftemangel der nach 16 Jahren
Misswirtschaft entstanden ist kann ein
Deutschland ja liebe Union nicht Kitten
verpflichtete und unausgebetete junge
Menschen sind nämlich keine Fachkräfte
das ganze ist übrigens auch noch irre
teuer und dazu wahrscheinlich
verfassungswidrig was sie hier versuchen
immer wieder nichts anderes als über den
Kopf junger Menschen hinwegzuentscheiden
und das nennt man und da habe ich noch
mein neues Passwort für ihr
road-vokabelheft adultismus
wir als Ampel gehen das zum Glück ein
bisschen anders an gegen den
Fachkräftemangel gehen wir in die
Offensive junge Menschen unterstützen
wir mit der Weiterentwicklung von
Freiwilligendienste und anderen
Beteiligungsformen für den Bereichen der
Engagement Politik erarbeiten wir Hand
in Hand mit der Zivilgesellschaft
Verbänden Wissenschaft und Wirtschaft
die neue engagementstrategie des Bundes
wir wollen neue Form von Engagement
absichern klare Kante gegen Demokratie
Feinde zeigen und für krisefestigkeit
sorgen wenn wir finden wir tun als Staat
sehr gut daran die engagierten in ihrer
Freiwilligkeit zu unterstützen
war das aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90
gegrünen bis vor kurzem die jüngste
Abgeordnete hier im Deutschen Bundestag
seit dieser Woche ist sie das nicht mehr
denn Emily Franz ist nachgerückt für
Heiko Maas den früheren
Bundesaußenminister der sein man da
zurückgegeben hat und die ist jetzt mit
21 Jahren die jüngste hier im Parlament
das hier ist Petra Nicolaisen die hat
heute schon mal gesprochen und kommt aus
der Union Fraktion
und auf einen Aspekt einzugehen der mir
sehr am Herzen liegt und zwar ist das
das Engagement in strukturschwachen und
im ländlichen Raum sowie in kleineren
Gemeinden in laut dem dritten
engagementbericht profitieren junge
Leute in kleineren Gemeinden besonders
natürlich von digitalen Engagement
Angeboten digitales Engagement ist
nämlich unabhängig von
langantragswegen von engen Zeitfenstern
von engen Themen und
organisationsvorhaben und einem meist
kleineren lokalen Angebot an
Möglichkeiten um sich überhaupt zu
engagieren
auch deshalb nimmt die Bedeutung
digitale Angebote zu davon profitiert
wiederum auch das Engagement
und das ist auch eine Erkenntnis des
Berichts digitales Engagement ersetzt
nicht klassische Organisationsformen im
Gegenteil digitales und nicht digitales
Engagement ergänzen sich denn wo es
vielfältige regionale Angebote gibt
werden diese auch von Digital
engagierten genutzt das Engagement
profitiert auch weil Digitalisierung
selbst zum Thema wird wenn
beispielsweise Jugendliche digitale
Lösungen für Impftermine zum Beispiel
entwickeln um Digitalisierung mit Blick
auf kleinere Organisationen zu stärken
braucht es aber nicht nur Geld für
Ausstattung und Software im
IT-Bereich es braucht zunehmend
wissenszeit Praxiserfahrung zum Beispiel
Umgang mit Plattformen und Datenschutz
und die kleinen Strukturen haben es
häufig am schwierigsten sich gehört zu
verschaffen hier müssen wir ansetzen und
die Rahmenbedingungen weiter verbessern
der dritte engagementbericht hat dazu
Vorschläge unterbreitet viele sind in
die Arbeit der Deutschen Stiftung für
Ehrenamt und Engagement schon
eingeflossen
als zentrale Anlaufstelle für Ehrenamt
und Engagement leistet die Stiftung seit
ihrer Gründung 2020 jedoch viel mehr mit
Informationen Beratungs- und
Förderangeboten und eigenen
Förderprogramm die sich verstärkt auch
an Organisationen in ländlichen Räumen
richten und da kann ich nur alle
auffordern nutzen die die Stiftungen
holen Sie sie auch in ihren Wahlkreis
mit der Deutschen Stiftung für Ehrenamt
und Engagement hat die vergangene
Bundesregierung einen entscheidenden
Schlüssel für eine gezielte und
strukturelle Ehrenamtsförderung
geschaffen an diesem Instrument müssen
wir festhalten die Stiftung muss
dauerhaft institutionell wie auch
finanziell gestärkt werden um noch mehr
in der Breite wirken zu können ich bin
mir sicher das wird auch ein vierter
engagementbericht erkennen abschließend
möchte ich Ihnen mit auf den Weg geben
als gemeinschaftliche Aufgabe muss die
Bundesregierung bei ihren kommenden
engagementpolitischen Vorhaben der
engagementstrategie und dem Demokratie
fördergesetz den ländlichen Raum noch
viel stärker in den Blick nehmen als
bisher denn seine Bedeutung für
Engagement Ehrenamt und
Zivilgesellschaft wird weiter wachsen
herzlichen Dank und eine schöne
Weihnachtszeit
nächster Redner ist für die SPD-Fraktion
Erik von Malotki
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe
Bürgerinnen und Bürger Entschuldigung
wir erleben in den letzten Jahren dass
unsere Gesellschaft weiter
auseinanderdriftet der Austausch die
Verständigung zwischen Jungen und Alt
zwischen Stadt und Land zwischen Arm und
Reich wird weniger wir stellen uns
deshalb zurecht die Frage welchen Kit
wir für diese Zusammenhalt unserer
Gesellschaft brauchen meine Hoffnung
liegt auf dem Engagement von jungen
Menschen und einer Stärkung der
Zivilgesellschaft der vorliegende dritte
engagementbericht zeigt hierfür enorme
Chancen auch denn junge Menschen wollen
sich engagieren und Team tun dies immer
mehr digital und non formal sie müssen
sich ein und werden für unsere
Demokratie gewonnen
gleichzeitig liegt im immer stärker
werdenden digitalen Engagement ein
Risiko weil dies noch stärker von
Bildungshintergrund der Eltern abhängig
ist wir dürfen diese steigende
bildungsungleichheit der engagierenden
nicht ignorieren sondern wir müssen
reagieren
der engagementbericht gibt hierfür gute
Vorschläge wie zum Beispiel das bessere
lernt von digitalen Engagement in den
Schulen aus meiner Sicht kann dies aber
für die Größe des Problems nicht
ausreichen ich zitiere mit Erlaubnis der
Präsidentin den Bundespräsidenten man
bleibt gerne und oft unter sich man
umgibt sich mit Menschen die einen
ähnlichen Lebensstil pflegen ähnliche
politische und religiöse Überzeugung
haben die gleichen Kulturveranstaltungen
besuchen die gleichen Medien nutzen eine
sehr wichtige Analyse aber was ist die
richtige Antwort auf diese Entwicklung
aus meiner Sicht kann die Antwort nur
lauten
Freiwilligendienste ausbauen und massiv
stärken so haben wir es im
Koalitionsvertrag festgehalten
wir müssen ein freiwilliges Jahr
schaffen das so attraktiv ist dass jeder
und jede es machen will was brauchen wir
konkret für einen solchen
Freiwilligendienst erstens mehr
finanzielle Sicherheit aktuell besteht
die auffahrtsentschädigung eine für ein
freiwilligen sozialen Jahr teilweise bei
330 € im Monat zum Vergleich beim
freiwilligen Wehrdienst sind es 1500 €.
2 sie brauchen mehr Plätze im
Freiwilligen Ökologischen Jahr im
letzten Jahr gab es auf
3.258 Plätze fast
13.000 Bewerbung wir brauchen einen
Ausbau der
Platzkapazitäten sie brauchen mehr
Anerkennung es muss für
freiwilligendienstleistende Vorteile für
eine Ausbildung spätere Ausbildung und
ein Studium geben
viertens wir brauchen mehr
Tätigkeitsbereiche wir brauchen ein
freiwilliges digitales Jahr und wir
brauchen einen freiwilliges Jahr im
Handwerk fünftens
fünften zur abschließend wir brauchen
mehr Verbindlichkeit es braucht ein
Rechtsanspruch auf ein
Freiwilligendienst ich bin überzeugt
wenn die ein solchen Freiwilligendienst
schaffen dann werden wir die so dringend
notwendigen Begegnung zwischen Menschen
verschiedener Milieus ermöglichen und
werden gleichzeitig Interesse an einem
lebenslang Engagement Weg packen
Erik von Malotki war das für die
SPD-Fraktion und ich denke man kann
sagen die meisten seiner Feststellungen
sind erstens richtig und zweitens auch
nicht neu und dann stellt sich natürlich
die Frage warum in diesem Bereich nicht
schon längst sehr viel mehr geschehen
ist es gibt ja sehr viele Kräfte hier im
Bundestag die schon mal in Amt und
Würden oder in einer Bundesregierung
waren jetzt am Pult für die FDP-Fraktion
das gilt erst recht für die jungen
Menschen die ohne Engagement denn ohne
Engagement gibt es keinen Zusammenhalt
das war immer so und das wird auch immer
so bleiben jedoch wie wir uns einbringen
unterliegt einem Wandel da bricht über
das junge Engagement im digitalen
Zeitalter hat für uns zwei positive
Botschaften zum einen gibt es auf
polnischerweise eine Zunahme des
Engagements insgesamt zum anderen hat
vor allem das informelle Engagement
zugenommen diese Erkenntnis ist für die
Politik folgenreich denn bei Engagement
denken wir meistens ein Verein
jedoch Digitalisierung verändert die
Zusammenarbeit als auch die Ansprüche
der engagierten die Menschen arbeiten
inzwischen häufiger ortsunabhängig eher
Projekt und themenzentriert zusammen
feststellen lässt sich bei den Jungen
eine Vorliebe für flache Hierarchien
kurze Kommunikations- und
Entscheidungswege und der Wunsch
politisch wirksam zu sein gleichzeitig
werden formelle Mitgliedschaften und
Ämter eher gemieden immer häufiger
engagieren sich nicht Mitglieder die
Niedrigschwelligkeit für Engagement ist
folglich sehr viel wichtiger geworden
auch forschen lassen muss uns
Parlamentarier junge Menschen schließen
immer häufiger die Mitgliedschaft in
einer politischen Partei aus gerade wenn
der Trend zum informellen Engagement
geht dann müssen wir uns Gedanken machen
wie wir engagierten Bürgern Teilhabe
ermöglichen hier spielt das digitale
eine immer größere Rolle die
Digitalisierung sollte einerseits für
mehr Menschen verständlicher sein denn
wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass
Engagement in der Freizeit stattfindet
und die Digitalisierung eben kein
Selbstzweck ist zweitens die digitale
Plattform werden wichtiger weil sie gute
Rahmenbedingungen schaffen können und
vieles einfacher machen und drittens der
Bürokratieabbau ist gerade auch für das
Ehrenamt wichtig getreu dem Motto
einfach machen ich freue mich auf
zukünftige Debatten wünsche Ihnen allen
ein gesegnetes Weihnachtsfest danke
für die FDP-Fraktion der Bundestag
diskutiert über den engagementbericht
der Bundesregierung es ist der
inzwischen dritte und es ist die vorige
Bundesregierung gewesen die ihn noch in
Auftrag gegeben hat auch diese
ampelregierung wird einen Auftrag geben
müssen so hat es der Bundestag vor
einigen Jahren beschlossen proje
Legislative
islaturperiode ein Engagement
aus der SPD-Fraktion
ehrenamtliche Engagement für unsere
Gesellschaft ist und es liegt an uns
genau das zu unterstützen den Menschen
dabei die Arbeit zu erleichtern und für
die passenden Rahmenbedingungen zu
sorgen
in der Vergangenheit war es mit der
cdu/csu leider nicht möglich das
Gemeinnützigkeitsrecht ernsthaft zu
modernisieren und zeitgemäß zu gestalten
deshalb werden wir das jetzt in der
Ampelkoalition in Angriff nehmen denn
wir wollen an der Stelle etwas bewegen
wenn auch hier geht es um die
Wertschätzung dieser Arbeit und dazu
braucht es wirkliche Veränderungen die
zeitnah umgesetzt werden
[Musik]
die Gemeinnützigkeit die sorgt bei den
Organisationen dafür dass sie Steuer
Vorteile erhalten was genau gemeinnützig
ist das ist im zweck-katalog der
Abgabenordnung festgehalten dieser
Katalog der historisch gewachsen und wir
müssen Ihnen dringend an die heutige
Zeit anpassen nicht nur das es geht auch
um die Frage der rechtlichen
Unsicherheit für Organisationen denn
inwieweit darf denn eigentlich eine
gemeinnützige Organisation politisch
tätig werden und wie sehr wo hört das
eigentlich auf darf sie zu einer Demo
aufrufen darf sie sich politisch in den
sozialen Medien äußern oder droht sie
dann Gefahr die Gemeinnützigkeit zu
verlieren
meine Damen und Herren wir müssen
klarstellen dass ein Sportverein zu
einer Demo gegen rechts- und
Fremdenfeindlichkeit aufrufen darf ohne
dass die Gemeinnützigkeit dadurch
verloren geht
wir werden dort für klare Regeln sorgen
und auch dafür dass sie einheitlich
umgesetzt werden können denn die
Menschen sollen sich auf ihr Engagement
konzentrieren können das ist ganz
wichtig wir wollen Ihnen an dieser
Stelle das Leben leichter machen
herzlichen Dank Ihnen eine gute Zeit wir
sehen uns im neuen Jahr
das ist der SPD-Fraktion die Redezeiten
sind jetzt etwas kürzer am Ende dieser
Debatte und das war auch schon die
dritte letzte Rednerin in dieser
Aussprache zum engagementbericht der
Bundesregierung hier kommt eine Jansen
aus der Unionsfraktion ich möchte mich
heute an dieser Stelle einmal bei allen
ehrenamtlich engagierten und besonders
beim THW in meinem Wahlkreis bedanken
denn in der vergangenen Woche durfte ich
mal wieder bei einem Übungsabend dabei
sein und miterleben wie die vielen
ehrenamtlichen dort ihren Dienst tun sie
bilden sich aus sie lassen ausbilden um
für den Einsatz fit gemacht zu werden
100 Stunden Grundausbildung die ihren in
einer theoretischen und in einer
praktischen Prüfung finden gilt es in
der Freizeit abzuleisten und am Ende
geht es um Menschenleben und da muss
jeder Handgriff sitzen bei den
Gesprächen die ich immer wieder führe
wird eins besonders deutlich das
Herzblut mit dem sich die Menschen
einbringen sie brennen für ihre Sache
und wir können es nicht oft genug sagen
ehrenamtliches ehrenamtliches Engagement
ist unbezahlbar und unverzichtbar gerade
für uns in den ländlichen Gebieten
die Art wie sich Menschen engagieren hat
sich in den vergangenen Jahren verändert
und so sagt uns der Bericht dass sich
zwei Drittel der befragten Jugendlichen
ehrenamtlich einbringen aber nicht mehr
unbedingt in einem Sportverein sondern
vermehrt in Form von Projekten und zur
Vernetzung und dem Austausch nutzen Sie
dabei oft die digitalen Medien
grundlegend für diese neue Form der
Beteiligung ist jedoch eine ausreichende
Medienkompetenz und hier schließe ich
mich der Berechtigten Frage der
Kommission nach der Rolle der Schulen an
die Vermittlung von Medienkompetenz ist
vor dem Hintergrund problematischer
Kommunikations- und informationskulturen
im Internet unbedingt zu stärken denn
dem Grundlagen fehlen dem bleibt
Entwicklungschancen verwehrt laut
Bericht engagiert sich die Mehrheit der
Jugendlichen aber nach wie vor im
Bereich Bewegung und Sport und nach zwei
pandemiejahren sind die Strukturen im
Vereinssport massiv ausgedünnt das
belegt auch die aktuelle
Bestandsaufnahme des
Gesundheitsministeriums das
zukunftspaket für unsere Kinder und
Jugendlichen soll dem Bewegungsmangel
entgegenwirken aber wo wenn Turnhallen
und Schwimmbäder wegen des
Sanierungsbedarf schließen müssen die
Einstellung des
investitionspaktssportstätten stützt das
Vorhaben jedenfalls nicht denn
Sportstätten sind Grundvoraussetzungen
für Bewegung
Liebe Regierungsfraktion Engagement ist
wichtig und darum werden wir ihres in
diesem Bereich auch gut im Blick
behalten vielen Dank ich wünsche Ihnen
eine gesegnete Weihnachtszeit und wir
sehen uns im nächsten Jahr an dieser
Stelle wieder
eine ganzen war das war aus der
Unionsfraktion der letzte Redner in der
Debatte zum engagementberichter
Bundesregierung der diesmal das Thema
Digitalisierung im Mittelpunkt hatte
wird hellgelehnt sein aus der
SPD-Fraktion Sprecher der Arbeitsgruppe
Demokratie in seiner Fraktion liebe
Kolleginnen
Engagement und Ehrenamt sind Stammzellen
von Respekt und Aufmerksamkeit in
unserer Gesellschaft durch meine das
ganz buchstäblich wir haben es erlebt
bei den Fluchtbewegungen aus Syrien aus
der Ukraine wir sehen uns daran dass
ohne Engagement die Aufmerksamkeit für
den Klimawandel kein vergleichbarer
große wirkliche wache Aufmerksamkeit
wäre wir leben es im Einsatz gegen
Rassismus durch bürgerrechtsinitiativen
oft sehr junge digital organisierte oder
wir Erlebens bei BürgerInnen und
Vereinen die in Stadtteilen Heimat
schenken gerade für einsame Menschen
das ist auch der Kern übrigens des
demokratiefördergesetzes dass wir
diejenigen verstetigt und auch
längerfristig unterstützen die oft
eingefallenet oft allein gelassen gerade
für Respekt von Menschen die bedroht
sind von Verfolgung bedroht sind von den
Feinden der Demokratie unter die Arme
greifen das ist der Kern dieses
Demokratie fördergesetzes
Respekt und Anerkennung
bedeutet aber auch
wahrzunehmen dass Ehrenamt häufig nicht
inklusiv ist und wie der
engagementbericht auch zeigt auch eine
Unausgewogenheit hat in Bezug auf
Diversität im Besuch Bezug auf Inklusion
auf Menschen mit Behinderung und auch da
ist der politische Auftrag die Bedingung
zu verbessern damit Engagement wirklich
inklusiv sein kann abschließend aber
bedeutet denke ich Respekt und
Aufmerksamkeit auch eine oft unerzählte
Geschichte hier zu erzählen in diesem
Parlament sprechen wir oft von Menschen
mit
Migrationshintergrund mit
nichtstaatsangehörigkeit als Objekten
unserer Debatte über ihre
Integrationsfähigkeit ihre Einbürgerung
über ihre Abschiebung und sonstiges wir
vergessen aber dabei das seit
Jahrzehnten Migranten Selbstorganisation
und jetzt auch jüngere Initiativen oft
außerhalb von Vereinen sich tagtäglich
für Respekt und Aufmerksamkeit für
Anerkennung in dieser Gesellschaft
einsetzen und diese Leistung dieser
vielen Vereine und Initiativen auf die
wir viel zu wenig gucken die verdient
besonders unseren Respekt und unsere
Aufmerksamkeit vielen Dank
Helge Lindt war der letzte Redner in der
Debatte zum engagementbericht der
Bundesregierung möge an der einen oder
anderen Stelle etwas nachhallen oder
auch entsprechend entschieden werden um
die runden 29 Millionen Freiwilligen die
es in Deutschland gibt besser zu
unterstützen bei ihrem Tun auch wenn ihr
das nicht zwingen erwarten aber kommt
sicherlich eine ein oder anderen Stelle
etwas Hilfe durchaus hilfreich sein für
die Helferinnen und Helfer wir sind beim
nächsten Tagesordnungspunkt es geht um
zwei Anträge und ein Gesetzentwurf der
afd-fraktion im Deutschen Bundestag alle
drei Vorlagen beschäftigen sich mit
corvit 19 Maßnahmen beispielsweise will
die afd-fraktion das Impfungen bei
Minderjährigen AFD 19 Impfung
wohlgemerkt ausgesetzt werden sie möchte
eine Änderung des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes nämlich das
Masken nur noch freiwillig getragen
werden müssen und sie fordert in einem
Antrag die Bundesregierung auf eine
Ordnung
Rechtsverordnung pardon zu erlassen die
die maskenpflicht aussetzt also alles
drei rund um das Thema covid 19
teilweise ist das in einzelnen
Bundesländern schon erfolgt was die
maskenpflicht beispielsweise im
öffentlichen Personen Nahverkehr angeht
aber die afd-fraktion möchte es
genereller und wie Aussprache wird in
diesem Moment eröffnet erste Rednerin
ist Christina Baum sie ist Mitglied im
Gesundheitsausschuss
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
in wenigen Tagen werden wir wieder
Weihnachten feiern das Fest dass sie den
Menschen in den vergangenen Jahr zwei
Jahren am liebsten verboten hätten das
fest dass viele ein letztes Mal erlebten
in Einsamkeit und danach um danach
einsam zu sterben und einsam beerdigt zu
werden dieses Bild steht
eingetreten für das ganze Leid dass sie
den Menschen in diesen zwei Jahren
angetan haben
und Sch
Merz überhaupt dass diese Zeit niemand
vergessen wird Kinder wurden unter
Masken gezwungen und von ihren
Schulkameraden getrennt in eine Ecke
gesetzt sie mussten am offenen Fenster
frieren nur weil sie aus
gesundheitlichen Gründen keine Maske
tragen konnten und der Schmerzen wurden
ihnen die Teststäbchen in die Nase
geschoben und jedes Mal schlug ihr Puls
schneller aus Angst vor einem positiven
Ergebnis mit anschließender Isolation
eine Mutter schrieb allen Abgeordneten
dass ihre Tochter morgens gar nicht mehr
aufwachen wolle weil die Schule die
Hölle sein so wie es meine Kollegen im
Landtag kalt gelassen hat hat auch sie
im Bundestag das Leid der Menschen nicht
erreicht und so wie sie bei diesen
Maßnahmen falsch schlagen legen Sie auch
mit ihrer im Verherrlichung falsch aus
dem verniedlichen den kleinen Pieks der
einen jahrelangen vollen Schutz ohne
Nebenwirkungen garantieren sollte
wurde ein in eine Injektion die weder
den fremd noch den Eigenschutz noch
einen Schutz vor einem schweren Verlauf
garantiert dafür aber schwerwiegende
Nebenwirkungen bis hin zum Tod mit sich
bringen kann ich zitiere dr Beate Jäger
Internistin aus einem zdf-bericht vom
4.12.2022 ich habe hier Kinder behandelt
die konnten nicht mehr den Kopf heben
sie konnte nicht sprechen ich habe
gestern die Mutter eines Mädchens
gesehen dass seit acht Monaten die Decke
anstatt und gefüttert werden muss die
vorher völlig gesund war Zitat Ende das
sind nur wenige Fälle von zig tausenden
die völlig unnötig geimpft worden weil
für sie Corona niemals ein Risiko
dargestellt hätte
alle hier von ganz links bis zur CDU
sind dafür verantwortlich für das was
geschehen ist und auch für das was immer
noch geschieht um weiteren Schaden
abzuwenden bitte ich Sie deshalb
eindringlich entschädigen und
rehabilitieren sie die Opfer und
schützen Sie unsere Kinder indem Sie
dieses gefährliche impf-experiment
endgültig beenden und hören Sie auch mit
diesem masken-wahnsinn auf ich zitiere
Florian Hoffmann Oberarzt auf einer
Kinderintensivstation in München in
vielen deutschen Kinderkliniken
herrschen derzeit Zustände welche in die
Dritte Welt erinnern die Stationen sind
brechend voll und Eltern mit
schwerkranken Kindern müssen teilweise
auf Pritschen in der Notaufnahme
nächtigen Zitat Ende verantwortlich für
das gehäufte Auftreten von schweren RSV
Fällen sind laut Hoffmann und anderen
Medizinern maskenzwang kita-schließungen
und kontaktverbote
jeder einzelne von ihnen sollte sich
wirklich sehr genau überlegen ob er
weitere Schuld auf sich leiden möchte
stimmen Sie unseren Anträgen zu das wäre
ein Anfang vielen Dank
[Applaus]
die Sicht von Christina Baum auf die
aktuelle kurierten 19 Lage insbesondere
im Hinblick auf
kranke Kinder die nächste Rednerin in
dieser Debatte ist nesa hat über radari
aus der
spd-fraktionsärztin von Beruf auch
Christina Baum die eben gesprochen hat
diese Zahnärztin
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren täglich
grüßt das Murmeltier wieder einmal
dürfen wir uns heute mit einem Antrag
der AFD beschäftigen der jeglicher
Grundlage entbehrt und allein das Ziel
hat die Bevölkerung zu verunsichern und
ihre Gesundheit zu schädigen
man kann das inzwischen nicht mehr als
verantwortungslos bezeichnet sondern nur
noch als bewusst destruktiv heute auf
dem Menü ist ein Raunen der Antrag für
Sie mit ein paar Fußnoten von
überwiegend etablierten Organisationen
die dem Ganzen ein anscheinend vom
Wissenschaftlichkeit verleihen sollen
zwar bringen sie teils die richtigen
können aber verkehren deren Inhalt für
ihre eingeschrichtet eingeschränkte
Sicht der Dinge vollkommen nun wollen
sie also die Kinder die Impfung von
Kindern aussetzen
mal ganz abgesehen davon dass jetzt in
ihrer Fraktion gänzlich an der
Medizinischen Expertise mangelt um
solche Forderungen aufzustellen zu
können zu können mangelt es ihnen
offensichtlich obendrein auch noch an
der politischen es gibt in Deutschland
auf guten Gründen eine ständige
Impfkommission STIKO genannt die damit
befasst ist zu beschließen welche
Impfungen in Deutschland für welche
Altersgruppe empfohlen werden es ist
nicht die Aufgabe dieses Hauses an der
STIKO vorbei solche Entscheidungen zu
treffen oder auch sie nur zu bewerten
es geht ihnen nicht um die Kinder
ging es ihnen um die Kinder hätten sie
sich einmal ernsthaft mit den
Ergebnissen der Studien zu kurvitimpfung
bei Kinder und Jugendlichen beschäftigt
erst einmal ja das Risiko bei Kindern
und Jugendlichen schwer an Kurve zu
erkranken ist im Vergleich zu
Erwachsenen deutlich geringer das
bestreitet niemand ernsthaft
die krankheitsbelastung nahm mit den
verschiedenen Varianten des Coronavirus
ab aber es gibt Kinder mit Behinderung
und chronischen Erkrankung die daran
weiterhin ernsthaft erkranken können
laut Markus Hufnagel pädiatische
infektiologe im Zentrum für Kinder und
Jugendmedizin des Universitätsklinikums
Freiburg wird jetzt aufpassen Mitte
durch die Lockerungen der Maßnahmen mit
mehr betroffenen Kindern mit meist
diffusen und länger anhaltenden
gesundheitlichen Problemen sogar
gerechnet
Studien in Schild und hospitals in Texas
und Philadelphia zeigen und zeigen dass
es durch das sogenannte
postimflamatorische Syndrom bei Kindern
schwere Entzündungen an Gefäßen und
Geweben gibt die mit
herz-kreislaufkollaps und
mikrothrombosen mit tödlichem Ausgang
deutsche Mediziner nehmen die mögliche
Gefahr von COBIT 19 Langzeitfolgen für
Kinder und Jugendliche ebenfalls sehr
ernst für die Studie Augsburg plus am
Klinikum Augsburg sollen ca 500 Kinder
Mädchen und Jungen aus Kindergärten